I I just like to remind everybody no
signs please in this room no signs in
right yeah right and the other thing is
you know I understand that we are going
to be debating and talking about some
several bills that have some uh strong
disagreements uh strong views on things
um and that's exactly the way uh that's
that's fine but no reaction in this room
please uh this is not this is not a uh a
popularity contest um in the room so
please refrain from that uh and with
that I'm going to call uh the Judiciary
Committee uh to order and I'm going to
first recognize representative D Lorenzo
Alle of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands
nation under God indivisible withy and
justice for
all thank you representative D
Lorenzo all right all right the first
matter on our agenda is House Bill uh
1283 relative to end of life options and
I will recognize uh representative Smith
motion thank you Mr chair I move ought
to pass with Amendment and when seconded
I would like to speak to the amendment
I'm going to second that motion um and
uh uh represent Smith uh please
proceed thank you very much Mr
chair um the amendment which is
bill
with almost the same language except for
some
amendments that came from the extensive
public testimony that we had an
extensive um written and oral
Communications that we received from an
incredible number of citizens in this
state out of those responses we could
draw several
conclusions the first is that there
was strong
support for the amendment the second is
that there were those uh people in the
community who
opposed uh the bill for a number of
consideration it came clear to us that
on the merits of the
bill there were some changes that could
be made that would improve the
bill one is we eliminated from the bill
language including Physicians assistance
assist and the reason for that is in
this state Physicians assistants cannot
uh act on their own their actions have
to be supported by a physician and in
because of that and
respecting the rules and guidelines in
the medical community we eliminated
Physicians assistance and as as an
appropriate change the second change
that we made again having to do with
existing state
law has to do with
pharmacists um we had in uh
conversations first very helpfully with
two
members of the legislature who are
Pharmacists and uh and then with with
others who um wanted to make sure that
the role of Pharmacists was very clear
conformed with state law and
um and made it possible for them to
participate in a way that in this state
is appropriate I think those are
actually the two major changes that we
made because the amendment replaces
everything I am going to take a minute
or two if the chair agrees to talk about
why we have this bill in the first place
yes please
proceed yes please proceed sorry for um
almost 30
years in this country the practice of
medical assistance in end of life
decisions has been in
effect
as of now 10 states and the District of
Colombia have had this
experience we in New Hampshire have
looked at this year after year after
year there has always been public
support and there has always been and I
say
appropriately a
hesitant to add this to the list of
endof life options that we have in this
state of course we have um we have
paliative care and we have hospice care
we have end of life
directives and um I would
parenthetically suggest that if you all
don't have an end of life directive you
ought to because the state encourages it
it's a very important component of Our
Own Health Care it tells our family what
we care about and what matters to us it
tells our medical uh caregivers it tells
the hospitals and all of this is part of
a long-term effort in this state to
recognize that the one thing every one
of us
experiences is
death not one of us in this room will
be able to escape death unless you know
something I don't know and please do
tell me so the state of New Hampshire
has paid attention to this for many many
years what has happened however is that
we wanted to
see what was going on in other states
how did it work how many people
participate what were the pluses what
were the minuses and this went on very
carefully very very carefully um every
two years we had a bill every two years
this committee didn't support it and
therefore the house didn't support it
about three years ago something happened
that was very very important and that
was a group of New Hampshire citizens
came together to
decide take a break from just filing a
bill here and filing a bill there but to
really do do the kind of research that
had to be done do comparative studies of
what happened in other states see the
results um and uh and
also talk to people across the state to
advocate for this as one more
alternative out of that effort a bill
was
drafted um
we had a very a high level of interest
on the part of our colleagues who wanted
to join us in in sponsoring this bill we
submitted a bill that was similar to
what was suggested but had certain
changes to address it the very cautious
careful conservative look we wanted to
adopt in this
state if you have a horrible painful
long time degenerative
disease um but if there's no expectation
that you're going to die from that
within six months you are not eligible
to even be considered for this if you do
not have complete mental
acuity to make an informed decision you
cannot participate at this um and uh and
that's important you need two
independent
doctors um who make certain
decisions
uh one of the uh all of us received a
letter recently from a a doctor in
Oregon who has been involved in this for
20 or more years and explained the
process and the number of people and one
of the points that he makes that I find
most
telling and those of us who have and I
think most of us have
experienced with a loved one uh a
difficult end of life he said that many
of the people who have
requested uh to participate in this
program and have gotten the prescription
do not in fact use it but knowing that
if the situation becomes absolutely
unbearable they have an
option and that has provided comfort
that has helped to make end of
life options that much better I think
that's
important the other last point that I
want to make um well two the first I
cannot address the and I will not
address the issues of opposit to this
bill based on religious beliefs
believing in the separation of church
and state I have
not gotten involved on that but I
respect everyone's right to make that
decision for themselves if their
religious beliefs do are not comfortable
with this so be it of course there is no
compulsion but I don't think other
people have the right to determine the
religious beliefs of their fellow
citizens so I'm not going to go into any
detail on that but I am going to talk
about those with
disabilities some of you might know and
this is personal but I think it's
relevant that for 10 years or more my
husband worked for the disabilities
rights Center carrying
out our really shared commitment
to understanding that those with
disabilities in this state and in this
country are not necessarily treated
well and their rights needed to be
protected and it was with great interest
that I read the letter from the head of
the
orgon disability Council I think is the
last word or maybe it's another word but
it's that group the person who has been
head of that Organization for uh more
experienced uh correspondence
involvement concerns expressed from the
disability community in
Oregon and the concern is the only the
only concern that was shared with the
disabilities Rights group in Oregon was
that people with disabilities in Oregon
felt that they were being denied the
opportunity to take advantage of a
choice that people without
disabilities could participate in and in
more than two decades those are the only
complaints the only complaints that came
um to the disabilities Rights group in
Oregon
this is a perfect example of why it was
good that it's taken us till
2024 to decide to come forward seriously
with this bill because we can benefit
from the experience of what has happened
all across this country and make clear
that what we do in this country differs
dramatically from what happens in other
countries we do not believe in this
country in euthanasia euthanasia is not
legal um we do not follow certain
patterns or practices that exist in
other
countries what we are looking at here is
how to make sure that the citizens of
New Hampshire relatively few but still
citizens of New Hampshire have an
opportunity to have one more choice in
how their life ends
and um and because of that Mr chairman
and I talk too long I know that um and
thank you for not interrupting me but I
believe that is why um the amendment to
1283 is carefully constructed is sound
is respectful of all um uh communities
in this state and provides a beneficial
alternative that provides comfort
not only to those people who are nearing
the end of life but to their families
who can be with them and
participate and not find themselves in a
situation where for example given no
other options someone who feels
desperate feels the need on his own or
her own to end their lives more
violently thank you Mr
chair thank you other uh people wish to
be heard on this
bill Representatives on the amendment
I'm sorry representative Staples thank
you Mr chair and thank you uh question
did I understand that the the first
element of change was to eliminate the
physician as an assistant in this
process did I hear that correctly um the
yes we removed the language that would
have permitted a physician
assistant to have any role in
this but the phys a physician a
physician assistant right okay but a a a
fully qualified physician yes is still
in the process yes absolutely you must
be a fully
qualified
uh physician or someone in the medical
community who has the power to act on
his or her own whereas a physician
assistant cannot act on his or her own
and that's why that was eliminated
because we have to be clear about
responsibility and it also by the way
shows us the importance of
Licensing uh for those people who um
have incredible responsibility in this
state followup yes yes absolutely the
second was the role of Pharmacists yes
and has that been expanded or reduced
and does it go into the detail as the
type of prescription for the the dose
okay the answer to that is it does not
go into detail nor should it I believe
for what the actual prescription is
since I don't think anyone of us is a
pharmacist Maybe I'm Wrong um and I
don't know your drug use I know mine is
pretty limited um we don't have the
knowledge nor should we of what the
actual prescription should be what the
bill says is that those important
decisions are made by the medical
community but the amendment makes clear
what the physician what the
pharmacist's responsibility is and
accountability and
um and that we thought was was important
it that is what is specified in in the
amendment and so that is only for
producing and delivering during the
prescription is the pharmacist role and
not in direct attendance yes that is
correct thank you just to follow up we
specifically if you look on uh page one
of the amendment lines 23 to
25 it we included pharmacists but it
specifically says that a pharmacist does
not qualify either as a prescribing
health care provider or a Consulting
health care provider so pharmacist can't
they they their their role is to fill
the prescription and uh provide the
drugs but they can't they can't be the
ones that decide if somebody qualifies
prescription other other yes
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair and I I have a question hopefully
one of the sponsors of the amendment
could answer this for me is there
anywhere in here that provides for
somebody just signed an affidavit saying
that they that somebody self-
administered the drug because I'm under
the impression
that if there's no evidence to show that
the drug was self-administered how do we
know that they weren't
coerced into taking
it okay representative Smith do you want
to representative
Alexander I I just had probably an
irreverent thought and that is if the
tree falls in the forest and no one sees
it fall how do we know that it's Fallen
if nobody's documented it um in fact the
experience across um uh the country in
in 10 states in the district of Colombia
is that um with
hospice and don't forget each of these
patients must have been in
hospice um or having had
expectation and with the others who are
charged with providing Medical Care to
that patient they have to
document um what happens at the end of
life the death
certificates um uh do in fact show the
disease um or the
cause of death again I don't know the
medical
terminology
um and so that
documentation if I could follow of
course you know uh the chair might have
a more
legal legally based definition than I
ever could come up with I I I mean I
guess yeah I guess if you're asking does
there does is there something specific
in the bill that says there has to be an
a no the answer to that is no I'm not I
guess I just don't see that um is a
particular is a particular issue of uh
the the whether the cause of the cause
of death I mean I think it does the bill
does specifically say that the cause of
death is the underlying condition not
the not whether the person took them not
whether the person died as a result of
the medication or not so that I so I I
guess I'm wondering like I'm trying to
come up with some sort of hypothetical
here so say um my grandmother was in in
hospice um and my mom was with her and
she chose to take this drug of her own
accord and or at least obtain it right
like so they have it and then she
decides eventually not to go through it
but another loved one is like you know
what you should go through with it and
then it becomes a coercion kind of thing
after the drug is obtained right like
that's my like there's no sort of
affidavit to say that somebody signs a
under penalty of perjury that the person
self-administered it on their own will
that's my concern is like once the drugs
completely obtained where's the evidence
to show that the person who administered
the drug did it of their own free will
and they were not
coerced well I I mean I I I guess my
response to that would be the the fact
that the person has made the decision to
do it initially has that has been
confirmed by two doctors and you know if
you're I mean I guess guess if the if if
your hype if your if your theory is is
there could that potentially the
scenario that you talked about happen
yeah I suppose it possibly could it
seems to me it's pretty it's pretty
unlikely that that would happen I guess
we don't you know I'm not I'm not sort
of prepared to think that most of the
that we we need to be thinking that
family members are likely to be
generally coercing their their loved
ones to to do this I'm does it ever
happen yes it does happen and not only
in this area but in other areas people
get coerced in their old age to uh to
transfer property or do things like that
we hopefully we have a court system that
is able to address those but I I don't
see that as a particular issue at least
personally I don't see that as a
particular issue here yeah and I I just
my last point I submit to you that's
probably in my opinion more common than
you think it is that's all okay uh
representative tur yes sorry just what
just one statement on that I think in
general the construct around that kind
of thinking would be that we are
implying misbehavior as sort of the
default um as opposed to basically
saying if there's evidence of coercion
then that would obviously come to light
but absent that why would we imply
misbehavior or taking the affidavit
proposition a little bit further
couldn't that be coerced as well so I I
I I don't think there's a way sort of to
to handle this with the assumption that
essentially coercion would happen unless
there's some evidence that it hasn't you
know the if I could just follow up the
other point I would make on that and I
think that I think uh representative ter
ra raises a a very valid point is to a
to avoid a claim simply I me know if we
if the affidavit could be executed by
the the sort of next of kin who might
have some interest in The Inheritance or
whatever you'd have the same argument
well they they were Co first to execute
the affidavit and what it would seem to
me what that would mean is that you
would have to say some neutral
party has to be there at the at the
actual time of death or immediately
before the time of death and to me that
really Cuts Cuts against the whole idea
of this of of being let's make sure
someone makes a a voluntary decision
confirmed by two qualified Physicians to
do that
and then is able to get the prescription
they have to then wait 48 hours before
it can the prescription can be delivered
uh but then it's up to the person to
decide when to take it and I would
presume that most people would say I
want to do I don't want some stranger
here when I'm about to about to take
this medication I want my family here um
and so that you know that would be a
reason it would seem to me to not want
to
have some kind of an affidavit system
right at the time of death now
representative
Perez yes um I'm speaking to the
amendment um the amendment does not
change the bill entirely it changes two
small segments of the bill um it doesn't
change um the intent of the bill it
doesn't protect people and as far as
support for and against at the time of
the hearing in there were um
1,125 um online against the bill as
opposed to
658 for the bill now since we brought up
Oregon as a mentor of this um Oregon has
reported that 14.8% of people who have
taken the drug have had a adverse
reaction a huge adverse
reactions um hanging on to men meds
concoctions and these are a concoction
hanging on to meds is not a good idea
because they expire and my concern about
the disabilities that have been brought
up um in the UNH which it was brought up
disabilities in the UNH um survey the
two questions the second was do you
considered yourself disabled is that
what we're going to put on this next and
as far as who supports disabled the
National Council National not State
National Council on disabilities is
opposed to this bill opposed to
assistant suicide and the Veterans
Affairs State Veterans Affairs is
opposed to this bill they do not want
people with disabilities added on
Veterans added on like has happened in
other states and in other countries so
that's addressing the bill this bill
this amendment does not change the bill
it doesn't get rid of the
flaws and when we get to the bill I have
spoken to a lawyer who specializes in
medical male practice
trip thank you Mr chair uh with regard
to representative Alexander's uh
question
about documenting that the uh the person
self- administered if you go to uh page
eight of the amendment uh lines one
through like 21 talk to uh the paperwork
that is uh
required uh of the uh
Administration and uh everything else
with the qualified individual uh I I
think the important section here is that
uh on lines three and four it speaks to
the Department of Health and Human
Services adopting rules pursuant to uh
RSA
541 on reporting data relating to this
uh I think as in many bills the uh the
bill is the framework of the law and the
rules that the uh departments generate
later on are are the are the Flesh of
the bill that expands what is done and I
think if you were concerned about this
we could uh you know talk with the
Department of Health and Human Services
and make sure that something like that
is included in their
rules thank you other other comments
questions all right I've seeing none I
guess I the the the last thing that I
would say is I'm uh I am obviously I'm a
co-sponsor of the bill I am a strong
supporter of it I agree with uh
representative Smith's uh recitation
earlier and I guess the only other thing
I would say is I I understand that there
are strong differences of opinion on
this you know 30 years ago if if I had
been faced with this issue U I'm not
sure I would have had the same view I
have now you're you know you're young
and you sort of you know you're
Invincible uh at 74 years old I
fortunately knock on wood I I'm still in
relatively good health but uh you know I
I realize that I'm in the Autumn of my
life
and I want the the Liberty if if the
circumstances arise when I'm when you
know the choice is
endure uh terrible suffering or or be
able to end it in a in a more peaceful
way I want that option uh and I think if
you know if if if I should have that
option it seems to me that everybody
should have that option um I I
understand the the concerns that are
raised about you know this is the
slippery slope I've I understand the
slippery slope argument I've made the
slippery slope argument myself in some
contexts
but here it seems to me we the
legislature will be in control of
whether there are changes um to to uh
what is allowed now and I'm I mean to
me the key provision of this bill is
that you be within six months of death I
can't
imagine ever supporting something that
you know was was more than that that if
you that if you're not within six months
of death but you're severely depressed
or uh you're disabled or something like
that that that somehow is an excuse to
allow to allow uh you to end your life I
would say absolutely not and I and I
think that most people in New Hampshire
and around the country would say that
also um and so you know what that means
is the legislature has to draw lines but
that's what we do we draw lines every
Bill we're going to exect today I bet
you is there's some line drawing we said
you can do this but you can't do that
that's what that's why we were elected
so I think we can competently draw those
lines and I think where they're drawn
here are the appropriate lines any
further comment yes representative Lanza
Perez so I'm a nurse and I'm GNA say
honestly that um I really also support
um this um because I have witnessed many
people who have um died over the years
and I will tell you um as an off op
option is very um important I think that
having witness people who have died
through hospice um it's very hard to you
have medications in your home even with
hospice okay and um and you are um self
administering the I mean you are
administering helping them but with this
this is an option for a person who is
terminally ill has that six months or
less to um live
and that is giving them that option
again it's an option and I want to keep
on saying that option nobody was let you
say is forcing that person to take this
medication it is their option if they
was let you say um because many people
have witnessed um deaths before and this
is not easy it's not an easy part of
life um was let you say we all know that
we are we come into the world and then
we have to die and it's not a um was I
say um easy to witness death especially
with loved ones but at the same time uh
to give them the option to be present um
for families if they want what whatever
they want is their decision to make but
again I think it's definitely what you
have to think about is an option for our
um people in the state of New Hampshire
and um and that's why I need to speak up
about this thank you thank you
representor
perz first um there is no
standard of life expectancy for a
terminal ill patient no
standard secondly I have never fought
the intent of the bill I have only
fought the flaws of the bill hospice
requires you to have your attending
physician and a hospice doctor be the
ones to certify you to become
hospice can't we at least have that kind
of standard that at least your attending
Doctor Who has been treating you is part
of the
decision this is two arbitrary
Physicians or nurse practitioners based
basically there's nowhere in here that
says the Doctor Who said you're going to
die in 6 months is involved it says your
medical records but there's no
requirement in here that your medical
records requirement that your medical
records are reviewed if hospice has done
a wonderful job but yet we have a page
and a half in here protecting the
doctors yes I did speak to a lawyer in
another state who deals with
malpractice
exclusively I sent him the bill this
bill opens us up and you have so many
lawyers here I'm it amazes me this bill
opens up everybody for all kinds you
know you could have two doctors and set
up an
office and this is what they did for a
living they chose
to do this come on down fix the bill
there's no residence requirement here
fix the bill and if you want to talk
about people who wrote letters we all
just got a letter and this is something
that came up during the hearing that I
had never thought about the two young
people who came were afraid for their
peers that this would give them
it's okay to kill yourself we just got a
letter from a college student at the
University of New Hampshire a resident
of Rob Rochester opposing this bill by
normalizing the act of Endy one's life
with medical assistance especially in
the state where suicide rates among
youth are already too high you are
effectively stating that an acceptable
solution to Life's challenges is killing
yourself
this proposed legislation would
undermine all the good work the state
has done on suicide prevention that's
from a
youngster we're considering and if you
want to talk about
discrimination this bill discriminates
against people under the age of 18 with
terminal
illnesses what right do we have to do
that this bill is flawed raise the bar
raise the bar at least use the standards
that hospice
uses at least use those standards for
people don't let people send up a stop
by shop fix the
bill other
comments all right seeing none I guess
we're ready uh and I'm going to have a
roll call even on the amendment so uh
ask the clerk please to call the role on
this is on the amendment we're voting on
808h Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander
con rep Stapleton
yes rep gon no
clerk utab votes yes rep Perez no rep
Smith yes rep Horgan um yes rep D
Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep
cybert yes rep Divine yes rep lonza yes
rep Manos yes rep turer yes rep Ming yes
chairman Lynn
yes
14-6 all right all right now we are uh
well I should ask are there any other
offer yeah Mr chair I'd like to move
amendment number
second all right move by representative
Alexander second by representative Perez
um represent Smith if you don't have a I
have a copy if you want that's the one
suicide all right representative
Alexander would you do you wish to speak
to your motion yeah just briefly if if
the states sanctioning suicide I think
we should remove the council it seems
like it's not needed if that's some if
that's the direction we want to go so
thank you all right any other any other
comments I believe it's ludicrous to
have say on one hand one thing and on
the other the other thing and I know the
Coalition um for the prevention of
suicide which I have great respect
for um is against this um Amendment but
at the same
token what about we're allowing children
have told us Young young adults have
told us why bother why bother you're
making it okay to commit suicide and you
can call it whatever you want to call it
but it is assisted
suicide any other
comments so my only comment is I I I
just I have to say honestly I think this
amendment is beyond the pale it it it it
is sort of a poison pill that what what
is the theory that that even if you view
this as um as as the main bill here as
being some kind of assisted suicide
which I do not but even if you view that
as the case is is the answer to that to
say we the people who say we are opposed
to Suicide the answer by this amendment
is to say well then we'll we'll just
we'll allow even more suicide how does
that how does that make any sense it
just seems to me it it
I I I have difficulty understanding how
that could possibly make sense
representative
Perez in every state and in every
country that has adopted this the rates
of suicide have
increased and and have the states that
have other states that have adopted this
also adopted uh provision eliminating
their suicide Council so that we could
sort of encourage more suicide no no
it's but you say you don't consider this
assisted suicide what do you consider it
consider it exactly I consider it
Medical Aid in dying that's what I
consider representative
Stapleton thank you Mr
chair I took this amendment to be a
warning
flag not necessarily um a literal
Improvement or disapprovement to the
bill but a warning flag
because this is medical assisted suicide
and if we're going to allow suicide and
and creeping human nature to expand uh
things to other people who are on the
fridge Fringe or the edge the limits
start to move if it's 6 months maybe it
goes to
seven um maybe the uh terminal illness
uh expands into other areas of uh
infirmity or weakness or depression or
Dementia or Alzheimer's or any number of
things and this has already happened in
in other countries uh especially in
Canada uh that is now just uh put on
hold an expansion for assisted suicide
from mental illness they putting that
off for 3 years you can you can
structure um guide rail and safeguards
but you can't contain the variability of
human nature um unguided by maybe some
principles of Ethics or morality to uh
want an advantage to expand it to their
particular case and then we feel sorry
for the PO people who don't know who
they are the Dementia or um Down
syndrome or any number of maladies and
infirmities I just see this as a
creeping toward it and this is the
warning flag um we're we're opening a
dangerous door here and I have many
constituents and myself too that under
moral uh beliefs and Faith beliefs that
this is tampering with God's Providence
in the protection of life and the
sanctity of life in the gift that's
given us us and ignoring the hope that
we had development that we have in
hospice and pallative care and kind of
setting that aside and say okay let's
put this one out
there and I see that there are there are
a number of problems with this whole
thing but two of which I I focused on
you
have in one case a couple of years ago
we eliminated the death penalty in the
state of New Hampshire
and one of the reasons we eliminated is
this cruel and unusual punishment and
it's death
by uh
injection uh and replaced other more
horrendous means and there's been a
number of failures botches and bungling
with this even in with Physicians and
attendance and we're going to leave this
procedure up to the individual with or
without a
physician um and what about the
cocktail um this is just one place
that's not acceptable in society and now
we're going to make it acceptable in
special circumstances which again can be
expanded and probably will be expanded
as we've seen in other countries um I
can't go there we shouldn't go there we
should hold back from from this and
focus on the more productive and
life-saving and healing aspects of uh
good to high and pallative care I can't
do
this comments on the
amend yes and it was a warning that is
especially is specifically why I put the
bill in it is a warning that this is
going to happen here just like it has
everywhere else so
therefore my warning I hope is heard and
sorry you
right I'll I'll follow the sponsor of
the Amendments lead on this so Amendment
the amendment is
withdrawn now lost right um think so I
think there there any other
amend so I think we're on to the main uh
bill
um do I have um a motion of ought to
pass with amend represent Smith um I so
move Mr
chair all right any further discussion
on the main Bill yes representative
andw thank you Mr chair and thank you
everybody for coming
today this is a contentious bill either
way no matter how we vote
I am one of the older ones sitting
here and everybody thinks oh you you
look healthy blah blah
blah I have health
issues I have helped take care of my
father-in-law who died of
cancer there's nothing you can tell me
about death I have lived enough years
I've seen enough of it but I'm going to
tell you right here and right now I will
vote no on this bill because I do not
believe in assisted
suicide I think it's terrible I don't
think the government should be playing
this game I think there's a lot of holes
in this
bill uh the survey that was done by UNH
the second question that are you
disabled that really flawed me and made
me really open my eyes where are we
heading what are we
doing so I just wanted to make sure
everybody knew I'm going to vote no on
this bill and I will never change my
you any other yes representative whoop
representative gon I'm sorry thank you
Mr chair I
have not made very many comments on this
bill listening to what everybody else
has to
say and I have heard just about
everything that I would have said
especially from representative Stapleton
just a few moments ago who I think
knocked it out of the
park but one thing that has not been
brought up that I will say now is I
don't think we
have the
ability first of all I think this bill
is going to to leave this committee with
an otpa
recommendation but I think it's a pic
Victory because I think what's going to
end up happening is it is going to
change it will continually change until
eventually maybe not in your lifetime
perhaps not in mine but I do believe it
will be in
mine it won't be too long before options
start being eliminated and the only
option for treatment will be the 1283
pill because Healthcare cost keeps
skyrocketing and we're not doing
problem we cut cost by prescrib ding
pills medical procedures cost more money
pill cost a lot less money we can make
more of them
cheaper and eventually it's going to be
no pallative care is too expensive at
this point it's not really worth the
effort the only thing we will approve
this is the insurance companies the only
treatment we will we will approve is a
pill there won't be any
options and I don't think as a society
that we have the ability to restrain
ourselves the character to do it to
restrain ourselves because we can look
out around the globe and we can see
everywhere this is being done it
continually changes to expand the field
of who is qualified to where now even in
some countries parents are making their
decisions for their own children if a
child has a health condition then the
parent decides what to do about the
child and eventually it's not going to
be a terminal illness it's going to be
just because the child is difficult to
deal with and we're going to end up
having postbirth abortions for lack of a
better
term and it's it y'all could call it a
conspiracy theory or Nut Job whatever
but if you watch what's actually taking
place we have so devalued life in this
country and around the world
that's where we're
headed
and I I agree with representative L uh
Andress that there is not an amendment
you can make to this bill that can
convince me to pass
it thank you any other comments
representative
Stapleton thank you Mr
chair um not to repeat um representative
gon's points very well
but there was another thing that
concerns me we we set the parameters and
the safeguards and the guard rails but
once you put out the six
months that's a red line it glows in the
dark um relative to people seeing that
and seeing Oh there's a window of
opportunity
here and that's what suicide ideation
and tendency for ways out uh for
depressed and lonely people will see
that and pick up on it but who else can
pick up on it insurance companies
insurance companies are out there to
make money and if you have a case where
even before a six months terminal di Pro
prognosis you have a person that wants
to go for every protection and every
chance for life he can and the insurance
company is going to control the
procedure and instead of authorizing a
$50,000 cancer regimen or or
fix oh we've got this um death assisted
suicide thing we we're not going to go
the 50 Grand but we'll authorize the
assisted
suicide um you can't control human
nature and that's the uncertain variable
in all of this um
along with many other things that are
problematic here um I think it's time
that we got back to some basic life
value principles that comes out of
ethics and
morality and let's start striving for
better pallative and hospice care and
involvement with families and whatever
else we have to do instead of taking
what I consider a cheap way out this is
not a slippery slope this is a step off
a
precipice and I can't support it in any
way Amendment or
no right other comments yes
representative
Smith thank you Mr chair I I have
listened
respectfully as I hope I always do to
the comments of my
colleagues and what what makes me
sad is not that they do not agree with
this as an
alternative the whole principle of the
legislative process the whole principle
of a
democracy is that we have disperate
views we come to issues with different
perspectives with different values and
therefore it's when we come together and
talk about those in a positive way that
we can understand how other people
feel and we can help shape our
own our own beliefs and I think that is
very important it is why for
example that um I have always listened
with respect to to my colleague who
preceded me even though we disagree on
so many issues but I respect so the
philosophy that he brings and I want to
it my problem however is that I try
always to
do as we learned years ago on Dragnet to
listen to just the facts ma'am just the
facts and much of what has been said has
been influenced not by facts not by
demonstrated results not by proven
experience in other states but by
beginning with A prejudgment and then
trying to go on from there I for
example don't uh I'm aware of what has
happened in the Netherlands I'm aware of
what has happened in Canada
um I am very pleased that I live in this
country I can actually come up now with
three or four or one example of uh of a
a law that passed in Canada that we then
copied here wholesale because it was in
Canada or the same thing for the
Netherlands we have different ways of
reaching our judgments here and I value
those different ways of reaching
judgments I don't want to be ever find
myself in a situation where I am
quibbling about words where I am
quibbling about what does suicide mean
as against Medical Aid and dying um
although I see tremendous
differences I know that when people die
as a result of suicide very
frequently it's a violent
death very frequently it is an of the
moment decision and because the means
happens to be
available somebody acts on it whereas if
the means hadn't been there they might
not have acted in that way and waited
for a moon to change I know that most
suicides take place when the person is
alone some of that is because
they're of their mood some of it is to
protect their family so that their
end I think that's
awful I look at the statistics that come
um uh uh from uh about the end of life
that many
veterans shocking number of veterans
experience and because they've been
trained to use weapons they've been
trained uh to solve problems with
weapons they choose a violent death and
what does that
do to their families who they leave
behind what does that do to the
community what does that do to our sense
of obligation to those people who who
really we sent into a situation where
the first thing we expected them to do
is to give up their own
values
um this is not what this bill is about
and we live in a toxic environment I
doubt if there's anyone in this room who
doesn't feel
if not depressed at
least low in spirit about what is going
on around us about people dying about
violence about um disrespect for
individuals lack of concern for our
neighbor all of that these are tough
through
I believe that what this is is an
attempt to
address in a careful
narrow structured
responsible legal
way an opportunity to provide an option
for those
people who choose to take advantage of
this option and who are able to make an
En formed
decision about the end of their own life
and I hope that we can continue to
improve um hospice when we first began
these discussions in this legisl where I
participated in
1997 before perhaps some of you were
born
hospice was
paralyzed to
do what they now do appropriately which
is to address issues of pain and we've
come to understand different ideas of
pain over the time is hospice getting
all the support that it needs is
pallative care getting of course not is
any area of Medical Care getting all the
support that it needs absolutely not but
here is one example where it is
appropriate to pres I believe for those
few people who would be eligible and who
would choose to take
advantage to have this option and to
know at the same time that in a
democratic small D Democratic Society I
know represent of greason is going to
say we're a republic not a democracy but
that's okay for the point of this
argument I think I could say this that
the legislature will continue to be in
charge and will continue to say this
works or this doesn't work I can give
you a very clear example of that that
takes place in orgon a state we've
already mentioned and that is orgon
moved a few years ago to completely
decriminalize um drug
use and they have now come to
decide that that was not the best way to
handle the horrible problem problem that
we have in this country about drug use
and they're changing it's the
legislature that is looking and watching
and changing and keeping control um and
I believe that this
bill gives the legislature an
opportunity to act responsibly knowing
full well and one would hope with some
faith in the integrity and intelligence
of future legislators to know that there
will continue to be close eyes kept on
this and every other issue that is
happening at this moment in every other
room here in the legislative office
building and um I hope therefore that an
overwhelming majority of this committee
will join the rest of us in supporting
this bill and bringing it to the house
and then to to have the house be able to
decide whether to send this bill on to
the Senate where we start the entire
thing all over again thank you Mr
chair yes representative Greece oh thank
you Mr chair just real quick there's one
disturbing point that I did forget to
point out
earlier you are guilty of a class B
felony we're trying to stop somebody
from doing this we talked about coercion
in in trying to C somebody into taking
the
medication but what we have here is a
class B felony
penalty for trying to stop somebody from
doing it now it uses the terms coercing
or exerting due undue influence but we
don't Define what is coercion or or
undue
influence and it's going to become so
subjective that just simply no please
stop is going to be considered undo
influence so without those definitions
you're now guilty of a of a class B
felony so we're going to
we we we have
so devalued life and we want to make
sure that somebody can can take their
own life that we're going to actually
make a felon out of somebody who simply
tries to stop them from doing it and I
know you could think they're going to
duct tape their wrists to the chairs or
whatever that's not what's going to
happen it's going to be a please don't
do this and now you're going to be a
felon but since there are no witnesses
to all of this how are you going to
prove anything but with that I say we
move the question we've already been on
this for an hour and 10 minutes
representative Perez you have if you
have something new to say please okay go
ahead first of all I don't lie I have
been called honest to a fault and it has
gotten me in trouble multiple multiple
times and I had no
preconceived idea on this because having
seen people die and have working in
intensive care for many years I I see
both sides of the story but the bill is
what I have fought there's no residency
it has the word Pleasant in it it is not
a pleasant death for everyone that's
misleading why not just have the
standards that proven
hospice has had hospice has standards
for how you enter it but yet we're
eliminating those proven standards
and letting basically any physician give
you permission not even your prescribing
physician and California did change they
went from 15-day weight to a 48 hour and
the it went up by
65%
65% all I'm asking you to
do for the people you mentioned Oregon
how they had a law
that per you know for drugs and now
they're going to change it what about
all the people that suffered because
there was no criminalization of drugs
are we going to pass a bill with flaws
and then say whoops we got to change it
because this happened and this happened
and this happened why not just get a
good bill first I a and as far as
um those of us that are
Republicans we have have
principles we have our um platform of
principles and one of the principles in
this platform specifically say states
that we oppose euin Asia and physician
assistant
suicide I will not go against what I
pledge to
follow especially when we have a faulty
Bill any other yes representative Kenny
uh thank you Mr chairman just a real
brief comment um because I heard a
comment that really bothered me um a few
comments ago I completely reject the
idea that this bill would allow a quote
cheap way out end quote or any negative
connotation that I've heard we in this
room will never experience what a person
in that state is experiencing until we
are there and we don't know what options
we will value um until you're there
there um you know in New Hampshire we
value Freedom so some of these comments
have really really surprised me um I
agree with the sentiment from
representative Smith that some of these
comments are not based in facts so I
won't repeat those but this is a wellth
thought out bill that has been worked on
for a long time and studied it's a bill
of compassion not cruelty and it's a
dignified quote way out end quote and I
fully support it thank you
representative Andrew
thank you Mr
chair okay we want to base something on
facts I want to give you a fact and then
I want to give you a true
experience no doctor I don't care who
they are I don't care if you have 20 of
them they have no right to tell a person
you got six months to
live my father many years ago had an
accident he ended up in the hospital
I'll make this
fast he was mentally incompetent after
about 30 days the doctor said to me and
the rest of my family he will never be
any
different we knew my father didn't want
to live that way so we had all the tubes
and everything pulled from
him my
father kept
living my father's mental ability came
back he went and had Rehabilitation and
he went home he was in his 80s and lived
several more years so the fact is the
doctors have no real right to tell
somebody how long they're going to live
because they don't know no more than we
do thank you any other comments or yes I
have one um just real quickly I feel
compelled to tell this story a lot of
you do not know but about a year ago I
was really sick and um I actually
currently awaiting heart transplant
and I was if I hadn't got accepted to
the elad program which I have on me
right now that's why I carry a bag with
me everywhere I go um then I would be in
hospice right now and I would definitely
have had a year or less to live and so I
would have liked this option coming upon
the sixth month if I would have been um
I don't know if I would have been
accepted to do that or not but I was
this close and I would have like like to
have had that option and you know for
the record I don't want to die you know
so thank you any other
comments oh representative
Oregon yes I I was almost tempted to ask
for a substitute and not be here today
but um this is obviously as represent
Smith as we all know pointed out as you
all know we're all going to die
eventually and some of us some people
die suddenly some people die gradually
but and most people that lucky they do
gry gradually and they have some inkling
whether it's just days or months in
advance of that the end is finally going
to going to come and um that's always
been the case that's always going to be
the case regardless of what happens to
this pill but I think we already do
provide people who are near the end with
Aid and dying and this just changes uh
the way we do it in a limited range of
cases you know we um many many patients
reach a point where any of the
interventions that could be done to
prolong their life would be just as
likely to kill them as what they have
and some people some conditions aren't
treatable so um regardless of what we do
with this bill it's still a fact of life
that we're all going to die and many of
us if we're lucky we won't die suddenly
but we'll um you know be able to be able
to pass for some advanced warning and
we're all going to need some sort of
most of us are going to need some sort
of Aid in dying regardless of what we do
um do with this bill and I know I've
seen it I've seen it recently with a
family member and I've even seen it with
members of this legislature I know at
least a couple who I at least a couple
who you know some who are friends with
I've had to you know aid aid them in the
last uh weeks or months of their life I
didn't didn't necessarily do as much as
I wish I had so even you know even us
even as New Hampshire State reps we're
all going to die eventually and um so I
think we all need some sort of Aid in
dying so I'm I have some doubts about
this bill but I think uh I think it's a
step in the right direction and it's not
taking us off off a precipice and even
if there is a slippery slope we're not
you know we're not required to uh go
down that slippery slope and we often so
um I probably now I'm wishing anyways
that I don't know if I'm making any
sense but that's uh I think you know
we're going to need to provide people
near the end of their life with Aid and
dying anyway that's not something we
avoid doing so this bill just changes
how we do it for a certain uh limited
class of people so thanks any other
comments all right seeing none I what
I'm going to do and I'm sorry for the
people in the in the audience here but
I'm as you may have noticed our clerk
had to had to step out because she
needed to be uh briefly somewhere else
on another bill that it seemed to me it
would have been unfair to not allow her
to do that um and that's and probably
that's my fault because I let everybody
including myself drone on longer than we
should have perhaps but what I'm going
to do I I I thought it was this was an
important bill I thought it was
important for everyone to have their
full say we're going to take a very
brief recess until representative cutab
returns as soon as she does return we
will then I'll then call the uh question
and we'll have the vote all right so
time
all right all right I'm going to uh I
think everybody's back I'm going to call
the uh Judiciary Committee back to order
and I believe uh everybody has now had
an opportunity to have everybody has had
a full chance to have their say so I'm
now going to uh ask the clerk to call
the role the motion before us is ought
to pass uh on House Bill 1283 as uh
amended Vice chairman Wallace
yes rep Alexander no rep Andrews no
rep KH yes rep Stapleton no rep trip
yes rep gon no clerk kab votes no rep
Perez no rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes
rep D Lorenzo no rep Kenny yes rep
cybert yes rep divine
yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes rep
turer yes rep Ming
yes motion passes 13
to7 all right um representative Smith
may I ask you if you write the majority
report Mr did I get the short
yes I'd be happy to write it thank you
and uh who will write The Minority
Report representative Stapleton all
right
um and you know can I ask uh on the
reports um we're we're g to be we're
going to be here for a long time today
and we're going to have we're we're we
have the whole session tomorrow so can I
ask that reports be turned in by the end
please I'm so yes repres when do we
anticipate this going to the
floor my susp I mean it won't be next
week uh my suspicion is it'll be the
week after that that's F right
thanks right it can't be next week
because we can't get into tomorrow's
calendar in time right right right right
so all right um so next I'm going to
turn to uh house bill um
102 and I uh recognize uh representative
motion I would move um uh to pass and
I'd like to introduce an
amendment right is there is there is
there a second I'll second it seconded
right the amendment
is amendment number 2024
d930 and I'm going to pass it out to
everybody and I also have another paper
along as well
so I take one of each
down
also all right so the uh motion has been
moved and seconded and representative
kab would you like to speak to your
motion I would thank you uh Mr chairman
could you give us the uh amendment
number
930h
so I believe that this amendment offers
a balanced solution to a complex problem
I have reached out to everybody that I
possibly could and worked out with
anybody worked with anybody that was
willing to come up with this and I want
to thank everybody that came together to
work on this I really do appreciate all
of the
efforts at the end of the day I think
certain people will argue against any
change that doesn't put the entire
burden of the cost of requests to the
taxpayers and when I look at how much a
$110,000 request talks to cost to
taxpayers who have a home valuation of
500,000 in certain towns it's really
quite alarming and that's what this
sheet shows
us if you look over to a town like
Roxberry one of these requests would
$21.30 and if you consider that somebody
putting in the request may not even live
in that District it would cost them
0er and when you think about the fact
that that's only one request what if
somebody were to put 10 requests into a
municipality like that and it were to
$2,382 that's really quite a bit of
money for each of those taxpayers to put
the bill and then what if these are Big
requests to a charter school and you
consider the fact that many of these
charter schools have minimal funding and
they run on donations you could
literally shut down a charter school
because a request is so big and they
don't have the finances to pay for
it I went through and try to do all of
my homework on this I read through the
statutes of all 50 states in regards to
the right to know laws and 42 of the
states charge of the eight who don't two
of them allow you to deny burdensome
requests and of the six who don't charge
and don't allow to deny New Hampshire
included they all have bills to address
similar issues as what we're doing the
most free time allowed before charging
of the 42 states that charge is 4 hours
Massachusetts and Nebraska give four
hours free this amendment allows for two
and a half times this with 10 hours I've
also read through all of the cases in of
right to know cases in the New Hampshire
courts and I don't think that there's
anything more that can possibly looked
in be looked into at this point um there
is persuasive case law where it was
decided in the Hillsboro Superior Court
that two months of emails between two
city of nashu employees was too broad
and the parties were ordered to meet and
confer within 14 days to engage in a
goodfaith effort to narrow the focus of
the request to both the city for the
benefit of both the city and the
requestor the Supreme Court Court later
called out in that same case for the leg
legislative body to address this they
said quote whether limitations should be
imposed upon the scope of permissible
right to no requests or rather further
accommodations should be made in the
right to no law to address potentially
unreasonably burdensome requests is an
issue best addressed in the first
instance by the legislature with due
consideration for the Mandate of part
one article 8 of the New Hampshire
Constitution so what this amendment
changes is it adds a w in here for
Indigent parties to ensure that
information is truly available to
everybody and not stop because of
finances it requires that if a party
seeks a determination that the number of
hours may be unreasonable that a
determination is made by the udman or
the court within 10 business days it
also adds in a clause that b bodies
aren't liable if they act in good faith
to redact information if something is
missed we've heard from somebody
we've heard that some bodies are over re
redacting Andor sending these to
attorneys to redact for fear of missing
something and that's creating a backlog
at times with responding to requests
there's already no punishment for this
anyways in the Statue but this is just
making it crystal clear that there's no
liability if they act in good faith and
they miss something it's also explicitly
allowing for the use of automated
redaction software Tools in conjunction
with a person spot checking it which
when in statues in other states some of
the other states are are utilizing this
and I think that would be a move in the
right
direction and then it allows for a
charge once the time nears what has
already been found unreasonable by the
court and it encourages some
reconsideration or rather the request is
appropriate or if the parties can work
together without cutting off somebody's
request to narrow it down a bit and it's
important to note that it's 10 hours a
month from any public body who is chosen
to implement this via a policy this is
enabling legislation and you don't have
to implement it if it's not a problem in
your
town and the next month somebody could
put in another request that would also
reset the clock for 10 hours so this is
10 hours in a month um so this is a
problem that really spans small towns to
large cities we had sunap senip and Keen
in here to testify in support we've
received information from londondary
about the costs of the large request
select boards such as Goffstown have
voted unanimously to support the bill
and what we're doing is merely giving
them optional tools that they can
discuss on a local level and debate with
as much Vigor as we have here and I
really hope that we can support this
solution to give bodies the option to
use these tools and I'd like to once
again thank everybody who has worked
very hard to come up with this reason
able solution to this complex problem
and I'm happy to take any
questions um other representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative I have a I have a
couple points to make I I know this
amendment is kind of is a um a drastic
change from the previous Amendment
offered during our work session can you
please explain the differences between
the amendment you offered a couple weeks
ago and the amendment today and then can
you also talk about I know in the
previous Amendment it talked about um
vexatious requests is there any sort of
um language in here that would provide a
solution to what we or at least Define
vixa request um I I'm not against the
bill but I think maybe perhaps we should
study this more as a committee um
throughout the summer and kind of into
the fall so I'm wondering can you talk
about the the change in the amendment
and why you you like
let up on it in one Amendment and then
you started you like brought it back to
like the original bill I feel like this
is kind of moving it back to the
original bill can you talk about that a
little more sure thank you so nobody was
in support of that Amendment it was very
clear you you also weren't in support of
it so I pivoted back the other way the
original supporters of the original Bill
also W in support I talked to anybody
who was willing to work on this I think
I've done I don't think there's anything
else that could possibly be looked into
at this point I mean I have a
spreadsheet cataloged of all the statues
from all 50 states I just I don't think
that there's anything else that can be
looked into I think it is a complex
problem but I mean if there was some
magical solution available I think one
of the 42 other states that have studied
this before us would have found it I
think this is the best solution I think
again we are offering you know two and a
half times what the least free amount of
time that states of charge are offering
they're offering four hours and many of
them aren't even giving that some of
them charge for any time at all and many
of them it's two hours and there's only
two that are offering that 4H hour point
um so we did pivot back I think the
other one the other Amendment you know
it just got too complicated and it would
have put us in the place that we are now
which is the court constantly having to
decide that this is unreasonable and the
parties need to work together and I just
don't think that that's really practical
I think the parties should be able to
work together to narrow things down and
I think that will absolutely happen
um
when they're encroaching on that 10hour
Mark I think parties will absolutely be
able to come together with the town and
be like okay let's work on this and if
it's really not a malicious request and
I I do think it's important to note that
you know we're not nothing nothing here
is requiring that somebody is even a
resident of any of anybody so people can
be putting in requests from Florida and
just using this as a literally a weapon
to charge up taxes for other people and
that just is something that I really do
think we need to address um nothing else
just that I'm aware of can you just go
into and and have whatever amount of
whatever you want for free with no check
and balance and no vote on anything I
mean we vote on every single other
budget and waren article on it but that
you you I mean the fact that somebody
could even put in a hundred requests
into a municipality that's small and you
could literally have those people each
paying 20 grand and potentially losing
their homes because they can't afford
that I think we just I think it makes
sense um so yes it is a pivot back
towards the original bill but it does
address some of the concerns that were
brought up including the um Indigent
clause in here and also
allowing for um and also explicitly
putting in here that the body is not
responsible for civil damages um as long
as they're acting in good faith and also
allowing for the use of automated
software to produce the redactions which
a few other states have also put into
their statute so that is kind of the
reason for the pivot and if if there
was a agement on that other Amendment we
could have gone towards it but it was
very clear in the in the uh work session
that people were just not in favor of it
so that's why that's where we ended up
with this and um yeah thank you if I if
I could just follow could I just follow
up real quick sure so um what I'm so one
of the objections was by the New
Hampshire press Association who is upset
that this bill would keep them from
finding out information about their
government and holding government
accountable um so for in situations
where um it's it seems like the onus is
on the
requester to find to find a
solution with with the agency to like to
ask for the information like to find a
solution to narrow their scope I guess
I'm wondering like do you think that
this bill with a $25 an hour after 10
hours would hurt the ability for the
press to access government information
and then disseminate to the public thank
you for that question no I do not think
it would hurt it and there were I when I
went through other State statues that
was not a common theme that other states
were including any sort of exemption for
that I in looking at the logs of
requested data there were not requests
in those logs for from the media that
were taking over 10 hours so no I I
don't think that that would have any
impact at all okay thank you yes
representative tur then and then
representative deeno thank you yeah uh
thank you and and thanks for bringing
this amendment um I I was opposed to the
last amendment that was brought for a
range of reasons that that I won't go
into but I think it definitely took us
in a in a the wrong direction for
solving this problem it it was quite
subjective in terms of having to prove
things like vexatiousness and commercial
use that that really aren't easily dealt
with um and put a lot of burden on the
town in terms of process that might have
even exceeded the value of the the
protections that it was Des desired to
afford um I voted for the original bill
that that passed our committee with a
majority um passed the house um it was
it was sent back to us in a
reconsideration um and that's fine I
think the an honest effort has been made
to uh improve the bill in a few ways I I
particularly like that the the new um
that the the amendment offers explicit
protection for people who um would find
the cost of of paying the fee um to be a
financial burden the other the original
bill I thought offered the protection of
the Ombudsman able to say that the town
was or or MP pality whatever it was you
know was ex excessively estimating the
cost this goes further and says not only
might it not be excessive even if they
making a request that that does
legitimately involve a large amount of
time there must be a provision that says
if someone's going to find that
financially burdensome that fee can be
waved so I I think it affords a lot of
protection to the process um and I hope
if this passes that it would not hurt
91a but 91a I feel is under attack to
some degree with these you know uses of
it as a tool to
continually um put in large requests
with almost no sort of incentive to
reduce your requests um I think this
would make the process stronger and I
I'll will end by saying I also think
with the idea of automated redaction and
some other bills that we've heard that
sort of say that a town has to or a
municipality has to produce electronic
records electronically they can't sort
of just put it into a copying process in
order to increase costs um the the
ability to upload it into an automated
system all these things are going to
further reduce the time that it takes to
fill a request further reduce the number
of requests that might hit this standard
going forward and um you know I think
with the new protections that are added
hopefully you know I would like to see
it um continue to go forward as as we
voted the last time with with even
greater safeguards thanks other comments
yes representative Ken oh I'm I'm sorry
okay representative D Lorenzo and then
representative KY I apologize thank you
Mr chair and I have a question to the
sponsor
um I'm reading your chart um
representative kutab about the property
tax impact of $110,000
um
increase and I wanted to know first of
all
um what happens when
um there's a it goes through the the
town of City attorney and
um that makes an impact does that impact
Insurance thank you for that question so
just um to give a little background on
this chart I realized that I didn't I
downloaded this data from the Department
of Revenue which gives all the tax rates
in each town and I did choose the static
uh number of a 5,000 $500,000 home
valuation um most of these towns are
putting or many of these towns are
putting these larger requests out to
contract attorneys
and um so even if they have an attorney
like the city of naswa for example will
often put these out to a contract
attorney because they just don't have
the capacity to do it all but
particularly the smaller towns they
don't have an attorney on staff so
that's where that kind of came in from
and and
um we had in the log several examples of
these 10 $10,000 report quests that were
coming in and so that's why I put that
in and and I think it's important to to
just show that you know I think we're
assuming that oh these cost these these
are just going to cost pennies and it it
really doesn't and it adds up and it
depends on the size of the Town how much
it's it's causing and some of these I
think we should have a little pause when
a number is getting to be this high is
this request appropriate so thank you
but um just to follow up um so what
about when um the town's insurance pays
for the uh damages rather
than the damages being hit the town
budget oh so in terms of like redacting
the request the insurance would never
pay to redact the request they might pay
for a lawsuit with the town but they're
not going to pay for if somebody's
making a right to no request they
Insurance wouldn't cover the cost of
redactions that's not my question sorry
but this is so this this chart is
showing the $10,000 that that
they're the cost of kind of making the
the request available when you're
putting it to an attorney to go and
redact it so in terms of like a lawsuit
if the insurance picked it up I mean I
don't know what the impact would be
because I assume that the cost of the
insurance would increase but I didn't I
didn't go into that end of it well thank
you for your answer um that's my my
Prime question is how much you know
thank you other question uh yes
representative Kenny uh well I have a
just a comment so I'm I'm on um this
amendment too and I do no matter where
you fall on this issue I do urge you to
support the amendment um even if you
don't support otpa because I think this
amendment does um improve the original
bill um so I've struggled with this more
than I've struggled um on most bills in
the past six years I want to start by
saying that I know how much work the
prime sponsor has put into this uh
representative cutab is does her
homework she knows this inside and out
um you know and I've worked with her and
any question I've had she was able to
answer and I truly applaud her ability
to work across the aisle um and her work
ethic in general initially I was itl and
I will concede that I have accepted that
there is an issue and that perhaps the
legislature could uh Implement something
that fully resolves it um but answers to
concerns of the other side I truly was
going to support
otpa um but then I started talking to
committee members and it did seem like
many were unsure going back and forth um
confused on some parts of it uh and many
did Express the sentiment that they
would like to continue to work on it uh
to be transparent this would be a huge
change to 91a except the on budsman
probably the biggest one that I would
see in my six years so far um everyone
has admitted how complex this issue is
um
and this amendment did answer some of my
main concerns but I know there are other
valid concerns out there and I want this
committee to be able to be confident in
their position and take the time to look
into something so complex and although
the prime sponsor has um I know we've
had a lot of work and when that happens
historically it is Justified to study it
and allow the stakeholders and people
who are interested to come together and
um continue to try to find a
solution so I I know I will upset some
people with my vote today um but I do
urge the committee to pass the amendment
but then not support otpa but also not
support itl only support an interim
study um so we can hash this out keep
looking at it I promise this is in good
faith I'll continue to work at good
faith with the stakeholders um but I
think a lot of compelling points have
been brought to us and when we're
changing 91a in this manner let's not
rush it there is no rush thank you other
comments uh representative
Perez first of all I am very much aware
that this bill is a London Dairy bill
that came to cause because of London der
um and I when I was the only rep in
londondary that voted against it I
wondered why and then I found out why
okay um I have a couple of questions on
it what how do we Define financial
hardship I mean the stock market went
way down yesterday I could consider
myself a financial hardship because of
that you know I don't I'd like that how
do we Define that the other is multiple
requests from any person or entity to
the same public body within 30-day time
periods is one
request that I have an issue with
because with um town meetings and
Schoolboard meetings coming up
fortunately I haven't had to put in a
91a request because they're pretty good
about getting back to me but I know I've
asked for information probably in the
past month six or seven times from the
uh SAU office and probably three or four
times from the
town
um I I that I have a concern about
because when you get
information from one thing that often
makes you have to go deeper to find out
the next thing so I have a concern about
about that um I think and I think this
is great to do this but what I would
have liked to have seen is in the past
12 months how much have towns spent
on on a 91a now I happen to I happen to
have spoken to a Town
counselor in londondary londondary has
never
spent more than 10 hours much less on
any
individual's um right to know the
average is three hours
okay the problem they had is that um
Kevin Smith was our town manager for
eight or nine years and then he ran for
um Senate and they had 91a coming in
from all over the United States and both
both parties that was a huge thing but
in the past
year they haven't spent much as far as I
know on 91a so I mean are we fixing a
problem that isn't there or are we
fixing a problem that might be there
only for one or two communities so
um I I would like to see it looked at
I'd like to really see how much people
are spending I mean I can't believe that
some of these little towns are spending
over
$110,000 on um 91 a and then there's the
question why do they use a
lawyer when I can get my questions
answered by calling up and saying gee
would you give me the numbers on
this why are they using lawyers to do
this now London da may be using a lawyer
because they've had multiple lawsuits
not connected with
91a but recently but I just I I I just I
want to see it cleaned up a little bit
more I think Caitlyn it's a great job
I'm glad you got rid of the one you had
last time but maybe we can add in outof
state entities maybe that's one because
it was the outof state entities that
were causing the problem I know
in during Kevin Smith CER all right uh
my representative Andress and then
representative
trip thank you Mr chair uh Kaitlyn has
done a great job on all the background
work but I agree with my colleagues I
think this needs inm study this is a
complex issue this isn't something that
we can throw through and Well
everybody's going to be happy at the
other end there there are so many
questions and what is I think a
committee ha is needed I've asked people
questions I think each one of us on this
committee have probably asked others
question or obtained
information but the whole committee
doesn't have all the information I hope
you know what I'm trying to say
and I really question if this is still
constitutional I realize there's some
problems out
there but to me it's just certain towns
or cities why do we punish everybody in
the state of New Hampshire if there's
only a few problems I mean most towns
small towns I've heard of I've never
heard of any problem with 91a request
and uh I have a couple of questions on
here I'd love to give to Caitlyn on the
amendment
what does
reasonably described
mean and at the bottom of page one where
it says any public body agency may
suggest to the request a reasonable
modification that is a pretty broad
statement I've Done Right to no request
before and
you if the requestor isn't sure what I
want they ask me to be specific and I
think because I believe that if an
agency tries to
modify then the requester may not be
getting all the information they need
and they'll have to go back again and
then on page
two F the lot the agency responsibility
what does that paragraph mean uh cuz I
wasn't quite sure thanks right
representative trip oh I'm sorry did you
yeah go ahead sure I'm sorry goad so
they're reasonably described I agree
with you that that's that's a very
ambiguous statement but that's currently
what is already in law I'm not changing
that at all and in looking back in the
2020 legisl legislative session there
was a lot of back and forth and it was
they tried to come up with a better
definition and they just could not get
agreement on it so it was left it
reasonably described and
so I
think I think if you want me to be
honest what I've heard from some towns
at this point is that when they are
getting requests that they consider to
be huge requests some of the towns are
saying well it's not reasonably
described you need to reasonably
describe it and they're not denying the
request they're just saying describe it
better and it's a ping pong back and
forth and if if the party won't do that
then they end up in court um but there
is no definition of what's reasonably
described and I you know I think that is
part part of the problem but that's not
a problem that I'm addressing in here
and um in regards to the paragraph F
that was about the fact that it was
brought up that some bodies are over
racting because they're nervous about
getting sued and we heard that testimony
over and over and there was a
a kind representative from nasua who's
an attorney um that does right to no
request in mass in New Hampshire and
pointed out um um that this they're
putting something in here that
explicitly states that they wouldn't be
civil liable if they're acting in good
faith and they Mis racting something
would help to you know resolve some of
it as well as allowing them to use
automated software to produce redactions
um which is in a few other State statues
so that's that's what that paragraph is
is regarding so thank you all right
representative uh trip and then
representative Horgan uh thank you Mr
chair
I uh I think the amendment is uh greatly
improved I like the
uh the sentence on
uh 12- 15 where uh uh if they're not
going to provide the uh uh requests
within five days that they provide an
estimate of the cost of making a record
uh within 5 days I think uh that in
conjunction with
the on page two lines uh 15 and 16 where
uh you make the statement that uh prior
to charging any fees that the agency
creates a policy so that the practices
are
transparent uniform and consistent
because if you don't know what the the
uh agency is going to use for is uh
metrics for producing these records
uh the
uh the estimate they give you on uh the
first page means nothing I think that uh
having a policy that is transparent
uniform and consistent would Aid
immensely in people uh defining what
they is what it is that they want on the
91a uh request uh I'm a little uncertain
as to what transparent uniform and
consistent actually means
could could you provide some guidance
here yeah so the intent behind that is
so that people can see what exactly that
the policy is so that it is that's the
transparent part about it the uniform
part about it was there was concern that
some people were were worried that you
know hey I I really like Alex but I I
don't like Tim so I'm gonna charge Tim
more than I'm going to charge Alex
because I don't like I don't like him um
and we want to make sure that that's not
happening we should you know things
should be uniform so that we don't have
inconsistent practices and we're not
charging one person more than the other
um and
um in terms of
the I guess as you were asking that I
remember that rep Perez had asked about
the definition of a financial hardship
that has to be within your the public
body's policy as well so this is you
know given the the public body you know
just as they they Implement policies on
you know um tax AB abatements um they'd
be implementing a policy on how they're
going to how they're going to go move
forward with this so that's I think it
is really important to have a policy
like this before just deciding that
we're going to charge and remember that
this is this is enabling so bodies don't
have to if it's not a problem in a town
they don't have have to implement this
so Selectmen don't have to vote to
implement a policy and it's if they do
choose to implement a policy it's up to
25 an hour so that body may say hey we
only want to charge people $5 an hour
you know this is all enabling and and
giving that choice to the local level
control when there are these more
problematic areas so I think that that's
really important that we we do keep
things Fair representative
orgon well we've mostly talking about
municipalities and unfor fortunately
even if we pass this bill with the
amendment um there's still going to be
cases of long running disputes between a
citizen and you know their town or city
which maybe can never really be solved
because a lot of times the right to know
request people seem people uh are
looking for information which may not
even in fact exist or if it does exist
doesn't prove what they want it to do
but this also applies at other levels of
government I know there's a uh issue
I've been working on which luckily
doesn't hasn't involved this committee
with a particular State program that was
is basically being administered by a
contractor there's a lot of questions
about how the contractor operates and
why they were chosen
and those type of issues sometimes you
do need a wide- ranging uh right to no
request because the uh it's at least
there's the appearance sometimes that
the that the government body is actually
added acting in a way deliberately
designed to try to Shield itself from
91a and from public scrutiny so those so
there are probably are cases where
legitimately you do need to make a very
broad request in order to find out uh
what's going on whether all the whether
all of those whether that's I mean
that's not necess true of all the cases
where somebody's making a very wide-
ranging request but there are some cases
where that's a legitimate thing to do so
I
um not sure if this we probably do need
to improve the law somewhere but I'm not
sure whether this bill is the right way
to deal with h situations where somebody
either legitimately or illegitimately
has a very broad area of concern with
how the public body is working and as I
said it's we're talking about the towns
and cities but it's not not just the
towns and cities which sometimes have
this issue with the interest with the
members of the public so I I would
representative I think representative KH
do you have your hand up
yes thank you Mr chairman I
um served as a selectman for 15 years
from 2008 to
2023 in Seabrook I saw many time I fa
this kind of situation that uh
especially right before Town election
around this time of the year uh uh many
many you know people who wants to run
against each other
usually um uh requested many of these
documents that the whole uh
Administration is top of it you know
they they left all the work and just
doing this kind of job I think some of
the uh comment I just heard and not
knowing the the testimony I was not here
I think that more work need to be done
uh representative could did a lot of
work you know it's a tremendous work but
I think more need to be worked uh that
is my comment thank you Mr chairman
representative Stapleton did you have
your hand up yes I did thank you uh Mr
chair um page one um line 28 uh
parenthetical e um may suggest uh key
word there uh I like that that suggests
communication we can solve a lot of
problems with communication and that
that offers that opportunity to do so um
request a reasonable modification
again um may suggest and it U puts
qualification on um what they might
suggest um and I think again
communication is is key why lawyers are
involved increasingly because councils
and uh select boards are increasingly
worried about the liability for
disclosure of confidential or private
information and so might do a cursory or
an initial review but then they're going
to bounce it up against the lawyer for
the safety and protection of that so
that they're not incurring a liability
and I know in Claremont we had a
particular case where uh lawyers did um
redaction and so forth and I think a
thing came at about
$23,000 lawyers are expensive you know
130 150 125 bucks an hour it don't come
cheap but the need is increasingly there
because of the fear of liability issues
so we need this is a balanced and
reasonable thing for both parties and I
think um we should go forward with it
and get it underway right representative
Alexan did you have any representative
Manos thank you Mr chair
um representative kab has put in Yan's
work into this into this amendment and I
I applaud her her work uh I'm concerned
about some of the more underlying and
basic issues here which is that the
Ombudsman expires I think it's within
two years and also the cities and towns
excuse me the cities and towns are not
authorized to go to the Ombudsman to try
to resolve some of these issues and so I
would also be supportive of interim
study so that we can look at some of the
more basic issues and so that we can um
as rep Kenny said uh bring together the
the stakeholders and um and look at this
in much more detail and maybe look at
some of the more basic issues underlying
The Spill right all right I guess um I'm
uh I I mentioned this to representative
cutab before uh that I've got I'm
working now on my recommendation of her
uh enrollment in law school and one of
the because she obviously will do a
tremendous job there and one of the
things that will be one it will be her
strongest selling point is that um she's
willing to go to work for one of these
big firms uh working tremendous hours uh
and uh for the for the poultry sum of
$100 a year for for compensation um I I
I think
this I I guess I can't I can't help
thinking that we I think we sort of need
to reflect where we came from my we the
the house originally passed this bill
and then it was it was committed for
reconsideration because people said that
there were additional factors that ought
to be taken up well we did take up those
additional factors we had a number of
amendments that were considered um and
rejected um uh everybody sort of had
their opportunity to have their say and
I think as representative turr pointed
out and representative Stapleton pointed
out this does make substantial changes
to the original bill in the in the
direction it seems to me of the people
who said um you know this is uh who who
had the view of well there should never
be any charge um this does make a number
of of uh of uh concessions going that
way it it certainly does retain the the
option of having uh charges if towns
decide to do that but um it uh it has
the Indigent exception which uh I think
is is is an important step in that
direction um and and the other thing I
think is really important is there is
there a provision that changes the
burden of proof uh to uh uh the public
body um where if there's if if a matter
goes before the um budsman so I think
um that this that this is a very
appropriate amendment I really don't
think that um there's any likelihood of
further study result you know coming up
with some uh some additional uh uh
benefit and that really we're just
interim study means we're just going to
it's a it's going to end up being
frankly a plight way of killing this
bill the last point I would make on this
is this you know the idea of charging in
some circumstances for requests is as
representative cutab pointed out from
her Rec this is hardly like a novel idea
oh my God New Hampshire is doing you
know is is taking this giant step that's
just not true at all it's what we're
doing is is consistent with what's been
done around the country um and in fact
we're still as as she pointed out we're
still by having the 10hour thing as
opposed to two or four we're being much
more generous so I I think that we owe
it to the taxpayers to adopt something
like this and I will I will be voting in
Andrew thank you Mr chair I got a
question uh representative kab on on the
amendment number on the second page
Roman numeral
8 where was that information that part
of the bill taken from because it
doesn't go along with the original Bill
and that's what I thought we were
confused thank you for the question so
this piece was um in this piece was part
of the original Bill there were a few
changes to this line um and one of them
actually addresses kind of what R Manos
was talking about instead of just
allowing to go to the udman RSA 91 a7b
gives the option to go to the udman or
the court should the udman office go
away for some reason it it would provide
that alternative alternative option um
so I think that piece in there was
changed and then the other piece that
was changed was adding in the line about
the burden shall be on the public body
and establishing that the hours and
Andor costs to make the records
available are reasonable and that a
determination shall be made within 10
business days both of those things were
added but the other pieces oh and I'm
sorry the other piece that was added was
also on line 17 to include a provision
for the waiver of such fees for
requesters who are deemed Indigent
Indigent or who can demonstrate that
such fees would present a financial
hardship those were the areas that were
added to this paragraph but that
paragraph did exist
in the initial bill we've just made
these these changes to it right other um
representative
tur yeah just just one more thing I
wanted to sort of uh bring out as as we
were working this past week to sort of
refine amendments and I I had some input
into this um you know one thing and and
I guess I'm speaking to the question of
interim study even though that's not
really moved yet um it's been sort of
brought up um in terms of what could be
known you know
working from this original base of this
you know we had a survey that was done
by the municipal Association so we had a
baseline for cities and towns and sort
of what their experience had been um I
became concerned when I realized oh I
hadn't really been focusing on the
state's uh agencies and requests to
State agencies which I raised with
representative cutab and and again to
add on to everyone's uh accolades for
the work that went into this she then
turned around and I believe and correct
me if I'm wrong contacted people at the
state who fill state level 91a requests
um who also basically said very little
of what they do would be would would
would break through the 10hour um limit
for reasonable requests so you know I
was pretty adamant we shouldn't move
something from at the state agency level
unless we sort of knew that put my my
fears of that as well you know to rest
so I I really feel like a great deal of
knowledge is on the table right now the
next time through I'm not sure what
we're going to basically be able to add
to what we what we know all right anyone
else have anything to say representative
Smith thank you um Mr chair first
because I am a very active advocate for
privacy I just would like to know if the
incredibly wonderful representative gave
you permission to tell everybody what
her future plans are uh that's the first
question question um the second is I
plan to support the amendment because I
support the work that the representative
has done I consider it um uh the least
bad alternative presented to us um but I
do not believe in the end I would be
able to support the bill as amended
thank you all right all right are we
ready for vote on the amendment and I
think probably we ought to do this by I
don't know what do you think any anybody
object to doing the amendment by a show
of
hands all right seeing none all right
all those in favor of the amendment
please raise your
hand go ah have one two three five six 7
8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 19 19 to uh one
right
what yeah no I think I got it yeah I
think it's all right so uh hang on so
um all
right all right so
um now um I'm going to recognize
representative cutab for a motion on the
uh bill otpa as as with the amendment I
move otpa as as amended is there a
second representative Stapleton second
Stapleton all right uh any further
discussion I could bring up one more
Point
certainly so um I realized that I didn't
answer
um rep Perez's question about why
sometimes lawyers are involved and I
guess it's it's often because of the
complexity of redactions that are needed
we're not talking about giving over
meeting minutes and stuff that's an easy
thing we can easily give over meeting
minutes financial data it's when we're
talking about asking for wide ranges of
email records and somebody needs to go
through and redact um I know in goof
toown it was mentioned they go through
and they redact the person's phone
number out of the email and whatnot like
things that aren't necessarily meant to
be public if somebody has their social
security number in an email you you
never know what's in these emails and so
they have to go through and when
somebody's asking for a pretty
open-ended number of
emails they need to be gone through and
they need to see what what needs to be
taken out so that's why sometimes a
lawyer is involved in going through to
see what does or doesn't need to be
redacted and I think that's really the
area that's that's problematic so thank
you representative
Perez I understand now the redacting
because I spoke with someone at the Town
Hall about it and they don't have the
lawyer do the redacting it's my I mean
why would you pay a lawyer $450 to take
out somebody's name address and phone
number but that being said I have a
question uh the ACLU was against the
original bill and I believe the 91a
people were do you know where they stand
on this
amendment yes so they they had agreed
with another amendment and um but the
committee didn't support that on this
amendment they're not in support of it
um uh londondary is using Shaheen and
Finny at $400 an hour for redactions um
so I so that's a choice they don't have
to do that
correct um that is a choice to use but I
mean I guess they need somebody to
redact the record somebody's asked
somebody's making the choice to put in
the request so they've got to fulfill
the request somehow yeah all right um
all right we ready for a vote on the
main oh I'm sorry representative Oregon
I'm just going to say about the
redaction it's useful that somebody has
experience with redaction because it's
not as simple as you uh as you think
like there's aming incident um I think
it was the frm Scandal I can't remember
it was about where um they they
carefully blacked out everything on the
PDF files so was blacked out from the
printed version and then they put the
PDF files that they use to make the
printouts online and so if you happen to
use the text to spech feature you could
hear all the stuff that had the black
bar over it just because they made
whoever it was made a mistake when they
were editing the files and also another
issue is it's not just things that are
generated by the public body themselves
um and we've seen this sometimes here in
the legislature including this committee
people will submit
things to the body including uh
legislative committee sometimes that has
information that's not redacted which
probably should be redacted so when
we're making so sometime when the body
is making the record of what so these
records often include things that other
parties have uh submitted to it which
may or may not have been appropriately
redacted when they were received you
know like I think this committee uh I
think we can all easily think of an
example with a bill we're not doing at
the moment where we a citizen gave us a
big pile of paper which had lots of
information that maybe should have been
redacted but wasn't some I that's why
all right are we ready for a a vote all
right um then on the motion of ought to
pass uh as amended I ask the clerk to
please call the
role Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander no rep Andrews no rep Khan yes
rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep gon
Smith rep Horgan
no r D Lorenzo
Divine rep
Lanza
no rep Manos
no rep turer yes rep Ming yes chairman
Lynn
yes motion bails 9211
motion representative Kenny yeah I move
interim study second I second all right
seconded by representative uh Andress
interim
study anybody
um any further any further discussion on
this or are we ready to vote I mean I
guess I'm just not sure what we're going
to learn in an interm study I think
we've kind of beat this horse and I'm
just you know I I'm not sure what what
we what we're going to accomplish in
interim study I mean do do we have
actual areas that we actually want to
look into or is this just a polite way
of killing the bill because I just I
time Mr chair yes representative D
Loreno I happen to agree with
representative cutab she did put in a a
human's work on this bill and um I can't
see how we can go forward um at this
point Thank you so I'm I would say no on
interim
study I mean I think if there's if
there's actual work that people want to
do happy to work with them on it but I
mean that could be done now there
doesn't need to be an interim study for
it I just think it's a waste of
everybody's time that's all well I guess
I'm I'm oh I'm sorry yes representative
Perez see I think um putting in
something about out of state and then
perhaps getting rid of um multiple
requests to the same body um you know to
the same for 30 um that's just an idea
um my concern not concerned but being
aware of the fact
that it's this bill is going to go to
the Senate I don't know if we're beating
our head against the wall or not because
um you know I mean the senator from
londondary I understand is going to put
it before the Senate so I don't know if
we'd be beating our head against the
know yeah I guess I'm um you just a
brief comment in terms of The Residency
thing I I don't I mean obviously I
haven't researched this but I I would
think that there might be at least a
question of whether or not you
could um you could limit that to
requests for only people in the state
and words what
um if you're if if records are open to
everybody in the state what's the
rationale for saying that they're not
open to somebody out of the state I I
don't know I mean maybe there's an
argument for it but I it it it's not
it's not clear to me that that would be
that would that would be proper but any
at any rate I guess what I would say is
um I think I agree with representative
cutab I I will oppose interim study if
the next I assume and if that fails I
assume that the that there would be a
motion of itl candidly although
very much support the
bill you know I interim study does not
seem to me to make sense and so if that
if I would suggest I'm going to vote
against interim study and then that I
assume that there would then be a motion
of itl Representative Kenny I've heard
from so many people that we agree that
this is a complex issue so calling inim
study to continue to look into it with
stakeholders is absolutely not a waste
of time and I am coming from a place of
good faith I'm not just trying to kill
the bill I don't believe the
stakeholders are you know I I think at
one point yeah I was itl I think other
people would have preferred it um to die
but at this point we had an amendment
that the that some of the stakeholders
who have been very vocal liked but the
committee did not then today we had an
amendment that maybe more the committee
liked it more but stakeholders pointed
out things that we should look at and
consider when so many states have these
laws I understand one representative on
the committee has looked into it
but inm study gives us more time to
really dissect those laws decide what
could work here what couldn't I just
feel like if we weren't up against the
clock we would we would have continued
to work on this amendment with
stakeholders with committee me members
and try to get it to a I don't want itl
I won't support itl either I really
think a good faith effort to bring
everyone to the table work on language
um see if we can counteract bad faith
requests cuz they are out there but yet
offer the Protections in language that I
think a conversation is Justified in
continuing to look at it um so I don't
want to kill this bill I won't support
itl either and I really urge everybody
to allow the committee to work on this
thank you representative kab I mean I
guess if there's work that needs to be
done why couldn't we just get together
and do it now I mean that the bill isn't
isn't due out of committee so if people
want to come together and work on this
we can work together at now we can do it
we can do another work session on it if
people really genuinely want to in good
faith work on this um we could recess
this session and and work together in
good faith if if there's people that
truly want to come forward and come
together and do
that the only thing I say about that is
remember I mean if you're if you're
going to do that and that might make
sense you're going to need to do that
between now and next week because next
week will be the last that's that's
going to be our last uh time for an
executive session so here people
representative Kenny I again feel like
one week we could be in the situation
where we are rushed we're not all at yes
yet and I I just there's been a little
bit of a Vibe of rushing not just on
this bill and I I just don't think
especially with complex issues such as
91a that it's unjustified to kind of
pump the breakes um and again I I wanted
to do otpa but hearing the concerns of
committee members there is things to
look at and if we had more than one week
I would have supported what
representative kutab just suggested but
knowing that it's only one week I think
inim study is the way to
go all right anyone else um
representative Andrew thank you Mr chair
I concur with my colleague I'm not
trying to kill this bill just for the
sake of killing it but there are just so
many stakeholders out there and then I I
have to stop and thank number one the
citizens of New Hampshire
and where we are right now everything's
not balanced the stakeholders they're
not all happy some I some I and I think
inim study for me is the way to go and
I'd be happy to be on the committee
because I think we can see if we can't
improve everything and I don't see the
hurry of pushing this bill through I I
just don't I mean I think we have plenty
of time to see if we can't do better and
I know Kate has done a great job but I
think we need to do more thank you all
right representative Perez I have been
asking since day one to put
in residents of the town or business
owners in the town do not fall under
this and the argument is well if you
live in town and I don't I can just have
you put it
in I still think residents need to know
that they are protected because
residents are the ones who are putting
in 91a perhaps most of the time I don't
know so representative orgon if you have
something new to add please well about
limiting the residents these issues
often these isses often like affect
people out of the town if it's a town
issue or out of the state so I'm not
sure whether it be fair or
constitutional wise to just limit the
resid especially and also like I know
journalists investigative journalists
are concerned about this and frankly
which is kind of unfortunate
situation the entities which do
investigative journalism events in New
Hampshire are quite often not based in
New Hampshire simply because of uh
simply because of the condition of what
the local media Outlets are versus those
you know Nation Regional or Nationwide
so that's probably side of kind of a
side issue but it's been coming up you
know I don't think living at to
Residents would necessarily be a wise
idea but is something that could be
discussed um possibly in the interim
study process if it comes to that thanks
representative Khan thank you Mr
chairman I just my last word uh although
I mentioned about the interm study but
after hearing everybody's comment and
the subject is a very uh U intense
subject uh um and also you mentioned at
the last bill that we have to make a
draw a line I think the bill the bill
needs to be a bit passage and I think we
explore everything and I think we should
go forward with the bill right right
well the motion the motion right now
that's been made and seconded is for
interim study so um representative
Stapleton yeah thank you Mr chair um
relative I recall to we had testimony
from a gentleman who res resided in
Maine but had some typee of business
insance Over The Line in New Hampshire
and he was denied in rtk because he
wasn't a resident um and I think the um
Amendment takes care of that by opening
up uh not restricting to well right you
know what I should say what I should say
on that is remember we have the H we
recommended and it went and it was
passed by the house I think La either
last session or the or the week before
a bill that removed the citizen language
in two sections of the I of the uh of
the right to no law and change replaced
citizen with person so we've and one for
one of those I mean among other things
for that very reason the idea that you
know the city of Rochester could say
we're not we're not allowing the
publisher of the newspaper that serves
Rochester to get access to records
because he lives in Maine
it it seems to me to be just you
know crazy anyway all right so let's
call the role on the motion of interim
study Vice chairman Wallace No rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep con no
rep Stapleton no rep trip no rep gson
yes clerk have votes no rep Perez yes
rep Smith yes
rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo no rep
Kenny yes re SE Sebert yes rep
Divine rep lonza yes rep Manos yes rep
turer no rep Ming
no motion passes 11
to9 all right inter term study so who is
all right so who is going to uh you do
the report on interim study
representative Kenny you will be writing
the report yes Mr
chairman all right I need you to be the
serious you do a good job yeah know I um
we've uh we've been working pretty hard
let's I think it's good time for lunch
so let's uh what a what a concept let's
uh recess for lunch and uh how about uh
115 115 uh return at 115 okay everybody
thank
[Music]
yeah
all right um I'm going to call the uh
Judiciary Committee back uh to order um
the next bill we have on the schedule is
uh House Bill 108 2 um that's the one
that we formed a subcommittee and I um
we had a meeting of the subcommittee
yesterday um and I'm my I believe we
made some progress I'm just going to ask
represent tur I I think we're not
prepared to vote on this today but I'm
going to just ask representative tur
maybe to give us a bit of an update yeah
thanks uh quickly though
yeah the so you correct we we are hoping
to to not take this up today we uh
collectively
put together some language that I think
addresses the concerns that sort of were
raised to um cause us to pause a little
bit on that bill and hopefully clarify
the the intent of it so the the goal is
to get that uh Amendment drafted and in
front of a couple of people who
externally uh had had weighed in on on
on the proposal so that we can basically
move it next week sure all right yeah no
that's
yeah yeah no no no we we'll get that out
so you know just just a sort of a a
scheduling note my an my anticipation
I'm I hope I'm not being overly
optimistic is that we will get through
all of the bills except for the one we
just discussed 1082 and 1432 which is
the AI bill which we're going to have a
discussion on but not vote on for
reasons I'll talk about in a minute um
or I'm talk I'll talk about it later I
should say
um uh so my hope is that next Wednesday
we only have two bills remaining to exec
and what I'd like to do I know we I know
that uh Some people prefer to start at
10: and that's why I've been doing that
recently but one of our Representatives
has a particular reason to be out of
here early uh next Wednesday so I'd like
to start next Wednesday at 9 o' we only
have two bills hopefully we can get
through them relatively quickly and and
get out I believe doe two weeks ago that
I had to be out of here by five are we
going to be out by five oh no no no
we're going to be out actually we're
um forget that we're starting at 10: um
I because I we we've made another
commitment I forgot about that we made
another commitment at nine o'clock so um
we'll we'll figure we'll we'll figure
something out all right so let's go on
then to uh um House Bill 11:15 and I'm
going to recognize myself I make a
motion of ought to pass um is there
second second right and I like to I'm
going to speak to this very briefly
we've this is the one the bill about
terminating the tenancy when the lease
is over I think I have an idea what the
vote is likely to be on this this is a
bill we passed last year uh was killed
in the Senate uh We've I I don't want to
belabor it I feel that it's leases
should mean what they say and that
they're um that the Supreme Court
decision from 2005 whenever it was um
which basically says that the tenant can
continue to stay there forever um
doesn't make sense and should be
overruled and I hope that you'll support
it that's all I have to
say reprentative Kenny uh thank you Mr
chairman um so yeah I I through test
testimony this time around last time um
I I want to begin by addressing the idea
that this is just a simple contract um
I'm a 3L in law school but in 1l you
take contracts and um one of the first
things you learn that in contract law it
assumes that the parties have roughly
equaling uh equal bargaining power and
I've been a renter for quite a long time
at this point um and to act like there's
equal bargaining power just isn't true
um the dynamic is just not equal the
landlord sets the terms and the Tenant
uh takes it or leaves it and with a
historically low rental vacancy of uh
0.6% what are tenants likely to do take
what they are offered without the
bargaining power because if they say no
the numbers don't lie it's going to be
difficult to find another option I've
been
there uh yet a landlord almost
guaranteed again based on the numbers
will have prospective tenants uh lining
up
so it's it's important to note that at
the end of a lease um term landlords are
not left without any options regarding
uh to agreements they can change lease
terms increase rent decide that they are
no longer wanting to rent the property
decide to rent a property to family
members they can move into the property
um
Etc the only thing that they can't do
right now is refuse to continue renting
to the current tenant without giving a
legitimate reason conversely the only
thing a tenant can do at the end of a
lease term is decide whether they want
to stay and accept the new lease terms
imposed by their landlords or try to
find another place to live which is um
very very very hard that is why yes
tenants need protection that's why for
the past 39 years tenants have been
protected from arbitrarily being
evicted because we are talking about an
individual's stability a roof over their
head it's a
necessity and unfortunately any eviction
in this housing market is highly likely
to result in some period of homelessness
homelessness is not something a person
should be subject to simply because
their landlord would prefer to rent to a
different tenant yet homelessness grew
55% between 2022 and 2023 and that is
the highest growth
Nationwide and for the reasons I already
stated this bill would make this already
dire issue much much
worse I shouldn't have to State it but
it is a horrible issue uh that if people
get evicted it can disrupt children's
education it can make employment
struggles for the adults among a host of
other
issues
um so to sum it up I I don't think that
it should be easy to take away someone's
home uh and that's what we have right
now we we require cause good cause
strikes a balance between protect in the
property rights of landlords while
offering some stability to tenants and
that's how it should remain I think the
Supreme Court got that right thank you
Mr chairman all right any other yes
representative
gon thank you Mr chair for our young
colleague who's rented for a long time
things don't change a whole lot when you
buy because I'm not in a uh much of a
equal negotiating partnership or
relationship with the bank when I go to
buy a house there much more powerful
relationship than I am I'm subject to
their terms and they just tell me if you
don't like it go find someone else we
don't
care I'm not protected as as equally as
the bank is so just to give you one
example when I buy title insurance for
the house it's not to protect the title
for me is to protect the title for
them I get to pay for it but they're the
ones who get protected by it so life
does not change when you go and you buy
a house and if I don't make the house
payments there there's a procedure
called foreclosure and then if I am that
process the end result of that process
is I could be homeless so
it's a contract is a
contract and it either means something
or it doesn't we either enforce it or it
doesn't there's not a tenant on this
planet who does not know when their
lease is
up and if you know your lease is coming
up take it upon yourself be a big boy
talk to your landlord and say hey I'd
like to renew my lease or I don't think
I can stay here or whatever the case may
be but take responsibility for yourself
and do what you need to do and make
those plans accordingly are there
unscrupulous landlords yes are there
dirt bag tenants yes the world is full
of all kinds of examples of all kinds of
behavior and there's no possible way
that we can legislate all of that or to
prevent any of that however a contract
is a contract and if if you're mature
enough to sign it you're mature enough
to live by its
terms right other any other comments
representative stapled no thank you Mr
chair you mentioned the Supreme Court I
the state supreme court decision yes I I
want to emphasize it was long before I
was a member of that court because I was
going to also ask what what the basis
was uh that they they said you could
stay after the term of lease the basis
was I I sort of along the lines of what
representative Kenny said it was sort of
a pol a basic a policy issue of uh it
shouldn't be the fact that the contract
is
over um shouldn't be enough and I I
think the if you read the decision it it
essentially said that with respect to
what's called restricted property and
bear in mind that doesn't restricted
property means if you're a landlord and
and you own as as as small as a
2unit rental property as long as you
don't live in it if you rent if you have
a you know a duplex that you don't live
in and you rent both of them out that
constitutes restricted property the anal
the analysis of the Court was well for
for the landlord it's really an the
landlord all the landlord really should
be caring about is the economics of the
situation it doesn't matter whether you
know you have tenant X or tenant y it's
just the the only thing you're
interested in is is the economics of the
situation which you
know that's that's you make a contract
that says somebody had that it's over in
a year um it it seems to me that it
ought to mean something but but that was
the that was the anal it was sort of a
public policy um don't uh it's not good
enough that the term of of the lease are
over that's that was the argument yeah
yeah excuse me thank you for that
explanation I I I wanted to say that I I
agree with representative Kenny on the
points that he made I was going to make
several like that but he's already done
it um if anything the situation is worse
now than that Supreme Court decision and
for that reason I I know the law is the
law and it logically makes sense what
the bill says but under the
circumstances putting people out and all
of the impacts that will happen
until the market is relieved or in
better stead I I've got to go against
the bill all right other comments Mr
chair y representative D Loreno thank
you Mr chair I just want to say that um
tenants aren't pieces on a on a on a
chess board or a game board um when they
sign a lease and move into an apartment
they establish a home to give them one
year with with a 30-day notice to leave
for no legitimate reason except that the
landlord wants the uh wants to put the
apartment back on the market I don't I
don't think that's good enough I think
um we are in crisis here in New
Hampshire um there was a huge housing
shortage um and so I think it's a um
it's kind of a
human crisis a human needs crisis that
we're facing
thank you yes uh representative trip U
thank you chairman uh I believe when we
had when we heard the the bill I asked
the question uh does the supreme court
hearing also mandate that the terms of
lease not change and I think the answer
there was no that's correct yes you
could you can change the terms of the
lease yes you can change you can change
the terms so this is I I I find this
this whole argument that uh you know the
uh the uh tenants have uh
U rights to stay forever a little moot
because uh if the landlord decides to
raise the uh the rent and the uh uh
tenant doesn't pay it then isn't that
cause to uh remove them sure so it's uh
like I said it's it's it's one of these
things where much like representative
gon said uh you know the tenant should
know that their lease is ending and they
should have take some action the action
should be either to negotiate a new
lease or to find a new place to live now
there's there's responsibility on both
the landlord and the tenants part so
that's uh one of the reasons I support
the bill yeah you know just to say I I I
think you rais a very valid point and I
mean part of the thing that troubles me
so much about that Supreme Court
decision
is it you're absolutely right if if you
know this in terms of the um you know
what's going to happen in the housing
market um I I I tend to think if
anything it would be a positive but the
the the problem I have is this decision
encouraged is dishonesty by landlords
because it if the if the landlord you
know if the landlord just wants to get
you out because the lease is over they
can't do that because that that that
Supreme Court case says you can't do so
what do they have to do they have to
come up with another reason and they'll
find another reason they'll say I'm
going to raise the rent or I want to
have my brother-in-law move into the
apartment or um and and you know but why
do we want to to encourage the law to do
that why why isn't it enough to say we
had a year a lease for a year and now
the year's over and that's so that's
that again I I don't want to belabor it
but that that's one of the things that
bothers me about other uh
other anyone else wish to speak all
right then I think we're ready for uh oh
I'm sorry represented me thank you Mr
chair um I just want to address the I I
would like to say that I I agree um
fully with representative Kenny and um I
think the very idea that a contract is
just a contract as in this stack of
paper um is governed by just the words
that are in it is not right there are
plenty of business contracts that are
governed by by statutes and I think this
is and and those are set by policy so I
think this is one case where the policy
for housing um dictates that we should
itl this thank you all right anyone else
representative
Stapleton yeah the the drop dead term
date um this this is a home a residence
not a hotel room hotel room or
short-term stay I I can understand that
but when someone moves in with family
and establishes
residents uh and they just to cut them
off at the end of term um just seems raw
and hard and and contrary to what we
need in the state today uh you know
there's Provisions for tenants at will
and some contracts have those in if uh
the lease is not renewed um and you and
landlord permits you to stay uh you're
tenant at will until such time that that
tency is challenged or revoked
um I I don't understand why um there's
so many ways to um provide some leeway
here uh if you want to eventually remove
the tenant because you're going to
rehabilitate the place sell the place uh
have other tenants increase in rates all
of those seem to be like legitimate
reasons um and I just don't understand
the abrupt
termination you know you're done get out
and it it makes no sense to me basically
all right other comments representative
Perez so once my lease is up and I can
rent month to month I have full control
so the renter now has full control they
can give 30 days notice and say I'm out
of
here so we're giving full control to the
renter but I own the home I own the the
the place where's my control um my son
who lives in North Carolina was in an
apartment and he had a a a lease the
woman above her just had um a bird
feeder which wasn't allowed and he
complained that the the um squirrels
were all over his thing because of that
well they told him he couldn't renew his
lease because of that so because he
complained
so it's got to be fair you can't have
the tenant have all the say and not the
home the owner owner of the property so
all right other comments all right are
we ready ready for a vote all right so
it's the motion is
OTP uh and I'd ask the clerk to call the
role
please pleas chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews
no rep con
yes rep Stapleton no rep trip yes rep
gon yes clerk kab votes yes rep Perez
yes rep Smith
no rep Horgan no rep D Lorenzo no rep
Kenny
no rep Sebert no rep Divine no rep
lonza
no rep Manos no repur no rep Ming no
chairman Lyn yes motion bails 8
to2 well is there another motion Mr
chairman yes I move itl
second hang on who so who Moved
representative Kenny I thought you yeah
I motion I who second oh that's me
second
second all right any further discussion
on um on this all right I guess we're
ready to call the
role
Vice chairman
Wallace No rep Alexander no rep Andrews
yes rep con no re Stapleton yes rep trip
no rep
gon Clark could have votes no rep Perez
Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep
Sebert yes rep Divine yes rep Lanza yes
rep Manos yes rep turer yes rep Ming yes
chairman Lynn
no motion passes 12 to8 all right 12 to8
uh um who will write the majority
represent Kenny all right uh Kenny and I
all right then uh let's go on to uh
House Bill 1353 and I recognize uh
motion um I move a to pass and I'd like
to introduce an
amendment
okay all right so move by uh kab
seconded by
Perez so it's Amendment
20249 78h and I'm going to pass out a
copy I did email it to everybody kind of
late last night so I'm not sure if
you
for
are you missing I did I not I think I
may have so everybody got copy of the
amend you do okay I thought I'd ask I
neglected to pass out all
Kat so I did talk with um
the representative from the Nea to try
and address several of the concerns that
were mentioned during the hearing and so
that's what this amendment is seeking to
do um
particularly
um
on line on page two on line five you
will see that subpoenas shall be issued
by hearing officers appointed by the
Department of Education to hear code of
conduct violation uh hearings in
accordance with the following conditions
there was a lot of uh concern about the
commissioner of Education making these
decisions and so now we've made it an
impartial hearing
officer there was also concern about
this being kind of a one-way street
where the department
could issue these but then if if a
teacher or other licensed educator
potentially could obtain data that could
exonerate them that they wouldn't have
the opportunity and so I went ahead and
added in that opportunity also on page
two lines 22 to
26 in any adjudicatory proceeding
resulting from a code of conduct
violation a hearing officer shall also
issues subpoenas on behalf of a
certified educator at their request as
relevant to a code of conduct
violation um and
so um another thing that was brought up
was um
relative
to the use of restraint and seclusion
and RSA 126 U Already covers that and
it's not in the code of conduct so we
did go ahead and remove it from here
another issue that was brought up was
there was
concern that um one of the topics was a
little bit um Broad and that's on page
one lines 26 through 27 we went ahead
and made it very clear that it was any
alleged failure to provide appropriate
supervision pursuant to Local School
District policy by a licensed educator
which resulted in harm or potential
physical harm we wanted to make it
really clear that this isn't talking
about you
know a poster on the wall I think was
the example that we were given and so
this is you know know a child was had
something bad happen to them so we've
gone ahead and put in all these things
and I believe let me just double check
my notes that I didn't miss any of the
changes but I believe that that
majority of the
concerns let me just see oh and then the
other
thing that was mentioned was to make
sure that the subpoena was relevant to a
coda conduct violation and that was also
addressed in here um onl page two line
six um so um and the last thing was in
here was that um on page two lines 34
and 35 any evidence collected pursuant
to The subpoena shall be made available
to both parties and any adjudicatory
proceedings resulting there from so that
both parties would get to to review
whatever is is collected um so I think
we've
covered much of the concern I know that
we did hear testimony that a lot of the
data that has been needed has been
granted from school districts however in
the howy long case for example it was
not they got to review it but they
didn't get to take a copy and I think
that's a very serious thing I think you
know we're talking about the safety of
children here and we shouldn't wait
until a new employee comes along to the
doe and doesn't have such a great
relationship and suddenly can't get the
data that we need and potentially we're
putting the safety of Children at Risk
especially when we've tailored this to
make it very clear that we're not this
is not meant to be a fishing Expedition
this is just meant to be if there are
very serious potential issues with with
children and the majority of teachers
are all wonderful my children have had
great teachers but we did hear concerns
that attent you know occasionally there
are bad apples Bad actors and and we
need to make sure that we're keeping
Kids Safe
And I think that this is a very
important important uh bill for that
reason and I hope that this amendment
addresses many other concerns and I'm
happy to answer any questions on it uh
if anybody has any all right um
representative turer uh I'm just curious
has the Nea weighed in on this since the
on this amendment uh are they now
supportive of it or or is that sort of
an open
question so the Nea has reviewed it and
they've kind of gone back and forth
trying to reach consensus on it and just
overall kind of were having a little bit
of trouble because they were there was
concern of well is this needed or not
but in terms of did this address their
concerns I believe it did address their
concerns but not they still just didn't
feel that it was
needed other representative Oregon um
yes does
this they have in line uh just in line
12 on page one they talk about New
Hampshire Educators is established by um
RSA 29 and CC1 which um seems to only
apply to um licensed and certified
Educators so what does this do to um so
what what does it what power would the
commissioner have if there's U
misconduct by say an um so-called
education Freedom account provider or
not all of whom are working at schools
per se or there's also for example thing
called the Learned anywhere program
where you can uh get credit for
activities outside schools so and then
of course there's other adults who are
involved with children at least somewhat
within the purview of uh the doe so does
this allow the commissioner to
investigate uh problems um involving
programs like
that thank you for the question so this
would not address that this only applies
to licensed Educators who are licensed
by the Department of Education in in the
sense of them being able to potentially
take action on their their license so if
you're not a licensed educator then they
would have nothing to revoke from you
you know can I just follow up and that
is I I I just don't know the answer to
this question but if there is a licensed
educator who teaches at a private school
I assume that the that the department
would still have some authority over
that
person
I don't know the answer to that question
I can text the doe attorney to try and
find
out question to that is are they subject
to the code of conduct because we're
talking about violations of the code of
conduct so if they're not subject to the
code of conduct there can't be a
violation of the code of conduct so
enforce yeah I mean I I I just raised a
question if I I don't know whether this
is true or not maybe maybe the are I see
someone in the audience who may have an
answer to that question but is is it
possible for a c somebody who is
licensed as a teacher to teach in a
private school or does that if you do
that you don't you're not subject to
licensure anymore I I just don't know
the answer to that question I do know
for sure that there are some licensed
teachers at private school that are in
fact licensed but I'm waiting for
attorney Fenton to answer of course yeah
please
thank you chairman Lynn uh Barrett
Christina executive director of the New
Hampshire school boards
Association Brian Hawkins Nea New
Hampshire uh labor and management
working together uh peacefully so um to
your to the questions I I I don't know
if I have a direct answer but the the
code of conduct through the Department
of Education applies my understanding is
to all certified Educators regardless of
they're if they're teaching in
a traditional Public School a chartered
public school or a private school so we
may have a a certified educator at I at
St John's little catholic school down
the street here I pres I'm presuming
that the code of conduct in general
would apply to that individual the
challenge that we might run into with
certified
individuals teaching at private schools
is the priv private school may not have
their teaching staff may not entirely be
certified through the Department of
Education they're allowed to have
non-certified staff there is a mandatory
reporting requirement in the code of
conduct so if a certified educator
believes another certified educator has
committed a violation of the code of
conduct the certified educator who
believes the violation has occurred has
a duty to report to the Department of
Education so in a private school if you
had a non-certified educator who thought
there was a violation of the code of
conduct by the certified educator the
non-certified educator they could report
but they don't have a duty to all right
yes yeah I would just and I would just
add also uh in in a somewhat similar
respect uh Charters only require 50% of
their uh teaching staff to be um
certified and so you don't have all
certified
teachers in a in a in a public charter
school but I think your question
chairman Lynn is does the Department of
Education still have jurisdiction over
that certified educator I believe they
do regardless of where that certified
educator is teaching that that logically
would make sense to me if they were
certified I mean it's it it seems like
the disciplinary things we're talking
about
are that that not so much where you're
working but what you've your conduct and
and if the if I would assume that you
know take a take a whatever you know an
obvious example of some misconduct would
be having an inappropriate relationship
with a student just hitting a kid
something simple you lost your temper
and you smacked a kid should it would
seem to me if that's misconduct it's
misconduct whether it's in a private
school or a public school I would think
so logic and law though I mean it's you
know right all right uh representative
Smith thank you um Mr Hawkins you do not
have to answer this question um and I
want to be clear about that but could
you are you willing to tell the
committee what um your organization's
amendment certainly um without uh uh
relating my our original testimony we
still are opposed to the amendment um we
don't think that it fixes the concerns
um that we have
um that's our position on the amendment
all right other questions and of course
the underlying Bill all right other
questions well thank thank you both very
much I appreciate it I think you it's
been been helpful to us all right are we
ready for a a vote on the uh on the
amendment and can we do can we do this
by anybody object to doing this by a
show of hands on the amendment all right
then I would ask uh all those in favor
of the amendment to please raise your
hand
one two three four five six seven8 nine
10 all right 10 and those opposed please
hand four five
six 10 all right so 10 to 10 the
amendment fails all right
certainly we always forget to talk about
the kids who are suffering the
occur all right all right so
um so are we back
to the original bill then or let me ask
is there I guess we're back to the
original
bill
um of uh is there a motion of ought to
pass on the original bill so moved and
I'll second that um any further
discussion uh C yes representative couta
second
any further discussion on the uh the
main
motion all right we I ask the court to
call the role on
the o original uh Bill ought to
pass Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep con yes rep
Stapleton yes
rep trip yes rep gson yes clerk kab
votes yes rep
Perez rep
Smith rep Horgan no rep De Lorenzo no re
Kenny no rep cert no rep Divine no rep
lonza no rep Manos no repur no rep Ming
no chairman Lynn yes
motion bails 10 to 10 10 all right is
um right is there a
right all right
um all right any further discussion on
on this so we ready for the vote all
right then I ask the clerk to call the
itl vice chairman Wallace No rep
Alexander no rep Andrews no rep Conan no
rep Stapleton no rep trip no rep gson no
clerk kab votes no rep Perez no rep
Smith yes rep Horgan yes re D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes re Sebert yes rep
Divine no I mean yes rep lonza yes rep
Manos yes repur yes rep Ming yes
chairman Lynn no motion bails 10 to 10
all right so it'll go uh without
recommendation
um all right and representative Smith
will write and representative kab could
I ask you to write the the uh the report
otpa first motion the
otpa didn't
ad that that's a good question for Can
floor
does does it have to I mean could it be
otpa it can be okay I where we where we
just had a 10 to 10 vote so that but he
can go okay all
right
okay itl okay no that's fine I just
wasn't all right good right thank you
all right um let's move on I'm I I know
people
have reasons to leave and I understand
that so let's move on to HB
1368 um prohibiting termination of a
tendency based on attendance failure to
pay rent that was increased by certain
price fixing programs and I represent
recognize representative D Lorenzo for a
motion i'
make is there a second representative
Andress seconds that motion all right um
any
uh representative D Lorenzo would you
like to speak to your motion certainly
thank
you thank you Joe uh thank thank you Mr
chair um based on the information
provided by the bill sponsor who
identified the company as yield star I
did not know that the bill was about
price fixing on the Real Page app which
I believe is a subsidiary of
yieldstar I am familiar with the yield
page in similar multif family housing
software applications so the deal with
this bill is that
um there have been several
suits in States um against price
fixing on multif Family Properties and
what happens is that the um yield star
owns rail page rail page manages multif
family
housing rail page um has a financial
software package that includes the
property budgeting um um property
expenses income expenses budgeting and
on the income line the there's an
algorithm that is automatically into the
system that raises rent in steps and the
problem is
that when Real Page UPS those Rents It
it affects thousands of units across
their portfolio so the government sees
that that as price
fixing
um and so first of all I thought that
the bill we probably belonged in
Commerce Committee um since it was a
series of antitrust suits for Price
setting at any rate it is unknown if a
suit was initiated in New Hampshire I
think it would be unwise for a New
Hampshire tenant under nonpayment
eviction to test the courts by refusing
to pay the increased
rents I am thinking the bill should be
itl since we do not have a New Hampshire
ruling on it um it's not so much a landl
tenant issue it's a price fixing
issue I of course I would defer to our
lawyers on the house Judiciary Committee
to um tell me otherwise thank
you are there any other uh comments all
right are we ready for uh a uh vote on
the motion of itl then I'd ask the uh
clerk to please call the
role B chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep Khan
yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep
gson yes clerk votes yes rep Perez yes
rep
Smith rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo yes
re Kenny yes re Sebert yes rep Divine
yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos yes rep tur
yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 20 do all
right yes uh and representative V
Lorenzo could I ask you to write the
report certainly thank you Mr chair all
consent
all right um on
um uh I I want to uh here I want to ask
representative Manos to to uh uh discuss
this but I what I would like to say
before we get to that is um I think
we're not going to be ready to vote on
this today for a couple of reasons first
of all
um we without even getting to
representative Manos is uh proposed
amendment which I at least parts of
which I I think are very good and maybe
maybe even more than Parts but um the I
think there are two issues one the um
the
um the communications industry who um I
have who I think were here at the for
the hearing but I've had some po hearing
Communications with them have raised had
raised some concerns several of which I
agreed with and made changes one of
which I was
questioning uh until yesterday and I got
some further information that led me to
think that the points that they raised
about political advertising paid
political advertising that I had some
questions about I think they're they
they showed me some Authority that I
think says that they're correct
um uh and so I think we would need to
make some changes anyway then we have
repes resentative Manos has a proposed
amendment which I as I said I think has
some very valid points um and then the
last thing is um we have artificial
intelligence bills before four
committees um and I'm told that there is
there are some significant conflicts
between for example what we Define as
artificial intelligence so it's probably
not a good idea for us to send some to
the floor um right away um hopefully
over the next week because we do have to
act on this by next week and I I would
if possible like to move something
forward um uh so we're going to have to
act pretty quickly but um that's I think
probably what was likely to happen with
1432 representative Manos um I turned
the floor over to you thank you Mr chair
um uh my cohort on working on this
amendment is representative Corman and
he's here and so the committee might
want to hear from him because he has
expertise in this area this is um
representative gon's underlying Bill and
um I work to make some changes to it I
distributed the
amendment um my there are four different
committees that have proposed uh bills
on that intersect or relate to AI um and
those committees are our committee
criminal law Edna and election law um my
understanding is that representative
Smith communicated with the speaker to
ask him for about the possibility of a
special committee so that we could the
four committees could reconcile their
definitions of artificial intelligence
um and I think several of the bills
perhaps at least this bill deals with
deep fakes um and so that's another
issue that might need to be reconciled
across committees um so um the purpose
of my Amendment um is to um start with
representative gon's underlying Bill and
strengthen it and use um Professor
Corman representative Corman helped me
with the definition of artificial
intelligence the definition of deep fake
so we've um used those um um and
then um we
included um audio which I believe was
not included in representative Grayson's
bill um we
also as I understand it representative
gon had proposed that um for example if
I if there's a deep fake of me created
that shows me threatening another person
and I am arrested for
that that pursuing to representative
gon's Bill the person who created the
Deep fake would then be charged with a a
level of crime that corresponds with the
level of crime that I have been charged
with um and we changed that in this so
that the um
person that created the Deep fake would
be charged with the clas B felony and we
just left it at that um I think there
could be problems with um judicial
scrutiny on charging the creator of the
deep fake with um a with a level of
crime that's not related to the crime
that that person actually committed um
so that was another change we made um we
did take out the um section
on um election law and the reason that
we did that was because the election law
committee has a bill relating to Ai and
we felt that it was more appropriate for
them to deal with that constellation of
issues rather than for it to be dealt
with peac meal between two different
committees so we did that and um I
created a side by side comparison so you
can visually see the changes we made
because the version of the amendment
that um OS provided did not have the um
the interlacing or the interlining and
the red lining um so I think those are
the highlights of the changes that we
made but it might be very helpful to
hear from representative Corman with his
um deep Professional Knowledge and
academic
expertise I'm sorry representative
Corman I wonder if we could ask you to
just come up and share your wisdom with
us
please thank you Mr chairman for the
record Tom Corman I represent the fight
15th Grafton 15 which is W 3 of
Lebanon I was a computer science
professor at Dartmouth for 29 and a half
years I have degrees in computer science
from Princeton and graduate my
undergradu from Princeton my grad from
MIT uh AI I should say is was not my
research area my research area was
algorithms I co-authored the leading
textbook on computer
algorithms that said I chaired the
computer science dep department at
Dartmouth for six years and I had to
really keep a breast of what was going
on in the field of course I've I I've
actually been in computer science for 50
years and I've tracked what's going on
in Ai and I was very concerned about the
potential for misuse of AI so I filed uh
hb1 1688 which went to Edna and that
bill restricts what our state agencies
are allowed to do with AI and
subsequently I learned about bills in
other committees uh HB 1596 an election
law filed by representative Brennan HB
1500 in criminal justice filed by
representative mamila and then the bill
here filed by representative gon uh
talking with representative Manos you
know we realize that yes these bills all
have different definitions of AI and
deep fakes and it seems that that could
be a real problem going forward so we do
need a consistent definition ideally
what we'd like to see would be a place
in law that has the definition and then
the other uh parts of law just refer to
that particular section of the RSA the
problem is that with four bills being
filed simultaneously we have no idea
which ones go forward and therefore
which ones we can even reference so at
this point it probably makes the most
sense to uh just try to get a consistent
definition in each of the bills uh I
should mention also 1500 the one in
criminal justice uh it hasn't gone to
the floor yet but it was unanimously
voted for interim study by criminal
justice so it it won't really be acted
on this year the other bills are still
alive uh the the the one I filed um 1688
Inna is most most likely going to a
subcommittee um yeah
so we had concerns about the definition
of AI and also the definition of deep
fakes and in fact in the amendment that
uh that was distributed the one that
representative mtis and I wrote uh this
morning I discovered yeah we admitted
one other thing uh probably be good to
put in um and specifically about the
amendment that uh representative gon and
chair Lyn filed that that representative
maners and I were looking at one of the
things we realized is it's actually not
as much about AI as it is about deep
fakes so we changed some of the headings
to replace artificial intelligence by
Deep fake but we need a definition of
artificial intelligence within the
definition of deep fake so we left the
definition of artificial intelligence in
there um and then also as representative
Mano said uh our Amendment removes the
section on Election law because there is
a bill in election law
1596 and it just seems to make more
sense to allow that committee to work on
it but you I am very concerned that we
get the definition consistent we spoke
with representative Smith yesterday on
Sunday and and uh we're hoping to get
some sort of committee together to at at
the very least come up with a standard
definition of AI generative AI which
appears in in my bill and deep
fake right so I um no well thank no
thank you very much for that um I guess
what what I um what I I'd like to
suggest and I want to hear from others I
what I'd like to suggest is that we um
we not vote on this today and that very
quickly meaning you know uh starting uh
within within the next week we get
together with the four with the four
committees um uh to to sort of make sure
that we may not we may not be able to
cons it probably would not make sense to
com to consolidate them all into one
bill but what we should have is I think
as you suggest at least a consistent
definition of what AI is and what a deep
fake is um and then if there you know if
election law wants to have its its uh
bill for election law uh and us for
non-election law uh that may make sense
representative Gon Do you have any
this well I like the amendment uh and I
like what's been done I think it has
been done with really good intentions
and very well very well done uh taking
out the election law part of it is uh
completely acceptable I understand the
reasoning behind it I had put it in
there not knowing about the existence of
the other bills so no no issues with
that at all I like what has been done uh
I do think uniformity in definitions is
essential um otherwise we just create
chaos so I I I like I like the amendment
uh there are two things
that have to be in a bill for me to
support it and that is a personal right
of action the private right of action
where a person who as the victim can go
after the person who who's the
perpetrator and then a penalty for the
person who did it uh a criminal penalty
so the class B felony I'm all over that
that's that's totally cool with me um so
you guys you guys maintain the
objectives that we were going for there
at least as far as I was concerned um as
far as um uh putting it together with
with the amendment that representative
Lynn and I had um I'd have to do another
side by side with that to see if there's
anything that we needed to pick out of
there but just from first blush I like
this amendment and think we need to at
least take this see what the other uh uh
committees have and then make sure that
we have a a de definition going forward
but next week we need to have something
we we we need to take at least one of
these four bills needs to go to the
floor in the next couple of weeks
representative Alex preferably this one
um thank you Mr chair and I want to
thank representative gon I think this is
an important bill to start the
conversation with um I you know I
studied public policy and the first
thing you talk about when you you study
get your Masters in public policy is
public policy is a study of what
government should do and not do and I
think in this situation we should do
something right but we have to pump the
brakes on how fast this is being done I
think with when you have multiple bills
in different committees discussing
different parts of AI I think we need to
be very very careful about coming up
with definitions of things that we
actually don't know like what the
development of AI is going to look like
in six months from now like it's it's to
me it's a really scary Prospect like
this is something that's evolving right
in front of our eyes so I I appreciate
the conversation being started I wish
the federal government would act on this
and the states didn't have to but if we
have to act I think we should um but I
caution and I I just want to pump the
breaks on all of these AI bills I think
we're moving too quickly I think putting
together commiss I hate commissions
sometimes but like this is one of these
broad ranging topics that we have so
many bills in different committees it
might be useful to do a commission or a
study committee or something like that
but looking at the the language of this
and then comparing it to other bills and
other committees I think we're moving
way too quick so I just caution the
committee and the legislature to slow
down a little bit let's take a breath
figure out what the best steps forward
are let's study it and then move forward
with the best product when we know what
we're actually talking about thanks what
representative Manos thank you I ju I
just wanted to um point out to
representative grion in in particular
that on page two Roman numeral 2 we do
have a private right of action so that
is in there and could you just remind me
was changed the the penalty
for you're your example of you you
somebody makes a video of you harming
someone there's a penalty that goes with
that you've been arrested for that so
it's determined is a deep fake that the
charging somebody with the crime
equivalent to the crime that you were
you just made a class be felony right
I'm okay with that so you protected the
two things I wanted to be protected yes
representative M um the other thing I
wanted to just emphasize is that we did
put in here because one of the outcomes
of this situation if if somebody makes a
deep fake of me threatening somebody and
I'm arrested for that then I'm going to
have expenses of Defense I'm going to
have costs for a an expert to say this
is a deep fake and it isn't reality and
so we did add in here that you can um
also recover your a cost for defense and
for uh uh
Witnesses
yes representative Andrew thank you Mr
chair after listening to everybody and
being not being knowledgeable in this
whole area I believe that either interim
study or a commission or something
whatever you want to do should come
about I mean if we have four
bills and everybody's putting in their
own definitions we're wasting a lot of
time and I believe people should get
together from all four committee
and come up with standard
definitions right other representative
Perez I think we need to put something
in place sooner rather than later and
then as we were told on earlier bills
the legislation can go ahead and tweak
it if they want
to any other comment yes yes sir please
go ahead thank you Mr chairman so uh a
couple of uh things I want to say to
representative Alexander's comments and
I certainly understand your point Mr
chair is this a member of the committee
or are we I guess I'm wondering like
where in exact like is another member of
the committee allowed to reut a member
I'm I guess I'm wondering like I I get
it if he was like a sitting member of
the executive session but I I I'm
confused well well
I if I guess we have a subject yeah
somebody who has a great deal of subject
matter we invited him to be here I think
we should hear from him so please please
continue thank you Mr chair so uh when
hb500 was heard in criminal justice this
whole question about the definitions
came up and chairman Roy actually came
to me afterward and suggested the very
commission that that people have talked
about and asked if I would be on it and
I said sure and he did contact the
speaker about it and the speaker did not
express interest in creating such a
commission so uh we would need to
actually
have some sort of legislation rather
than than something that the speaker
creates the other thing I would say is
that as a back stop if these bills go
through without consistent definitions I
suppose there is the possibility of when
they get to the Senate telling the
senate about this and asking them to
amend the bills to make the definitions
consistent you know can I well I guess
what I'd like to suggest because I I I
understand your point representative
Alexander but I guess guess what I would
like to suggest is is this would it make
sense
for um representative Manos myself
representative
gon um uh and I don't want to I don't
want to get a subcommittee too big but
but representative Manos myself
representative grion and hopefully you
would be willing to uh to join us as
sort of an next parte um to get together
early next week and see if we can I'll
I'll have been in touch with the with
the other four chairs see if we
can sort of fix this in a timely way to
be able to exec next Wednesday if it
turns out that we can't do that that
it's you know that it really is or we're
not comfortable because we feel like
we're moving too quickly then maybe the
appropriate thing is an interim study
motion but I would really I mean I agree
with representative Perez and
representative grion that to me the
preferred thing would be to move forward
just to make sure that we're doing it
consistently um with the other
committees does that does that make that
make sense as a way to move
forward man thank you Mr chairman uh
that does make sense to me I just wanted
to point out that the election committee
does plan on executing their version of
the bill on Monday Al I also sit on
Election so um they plan on executing
that all their bills on Monday they
don't want to hold on to any more bills
so just to put that out there but I
suppose if where if you were going to go
in the direction of keeping I know it
originally had the election section in
there like maybe that committee could
just itl it if you guys are going to be
fixing that particular area but just
wanted to point that out okay um do do
you ever do you have representative man
or does anybody Happ to know what the is
the definition of AI in the election law
Bill different than than this this one
it is okay all right representative
Manos I I just wanted to point out that
um or remind remind us that
representative Smith I believe did reach
out to the speaker he did decline it the
first time and then I think
representative Smith reached out to him
a second time to ask about a special
committee and um maybe that'll uh if I
could respond to that yes I did I sent
an email to him and copied the uh the
chairs and the rank ing members of the
four committees I haven't had a response
um we all know how busy he is um I uh
just a little while ago did send um a
copy of that to uh the chief of staff uh
to
say perhaps the speaker hadn't had a
chance yet to look at that okay and I I
did I I did the same I also um left
messages for the speaker saying I wanted
to talk you know talked to him about a
couple of things but this was one of
them and I haven't heard back from him
yet but um I mean I I will make it a
point to to reach out to him again um so
I guess I mean does that does that make
sense as a way forward to appoint this
subcommittee with an idea that we'll
we'll work we'll get together very
quickly um and try to try to do uh to do
something on this does that make sense
all right so then why don't uh uh why
don't we do that and uh we'll
hopefully we'll be back next week been a
we'll be able to exec this and thank
thank you very much cor really
appreciate it all right
um
um uh restricting trial courts trial
courts in criminal Matters from imposing
certain sentences following a plea
bargain um do I have a motion on that
anybody wish to make a motion on that
um all right well then I 1497 I'll make
the motion of
itl seconded by representative Smith um
I
um I think there's not a lot to say
about this uh it proposes to limit the
bill proposes to limit um a Court's
authority to ose a sentence if a person
rejects a plea
bargain
um plea bargaining is a huge part of the
criminal justice system over 90% of
cases are resolved by some kind of a
plea bargain
um
the if you actually had a system that
prevented
courts from imposing a sentence that was
um more than
somebody um more than was the subject of
a plea
bargain uh offer then Pro I mean it
seems to me that
prosecutors would know that and there
would they would adjust their ple
bargain offers in uh in in uh to to
account for that and the result I
suspect would be that uh criminal
defendants would not get the benefit of
of a plea bargain that they might
otherwise get the benefit of uh now um
so I I I think I mean I don't think the
I don't think the idea has any Merit but
even if it did have Merit um it you know
we certain that certainly hasn't been
shown to us by the one witness who
offered the offered the uh offered this
bill um and and and as he stated had you
know sort of has a had a
uh his his interest in doing so was
based on a personal experience so I I
think it itl is the appropriate U motion
here uh anyone else wish to speak
representative HG well it um it it
attempts to bind federal judges too
which I'm not sure what jurisdiction we
have over them and
also there may be cases where federal
judge might be inclined to uh uh make a
less favorable plea par than the state
state judge um either because just s the
standards with somewh offence are
different in those two those two courts
or also sometimes you'll have an
individual here in New Hampshire who
will commit a crime that cross the state
lines and obviously if they worked out
something with New Hampshire that could
only probably could only cover what they
did you know that's strictly within the
state lines but there could be a
parallel federal case that's going to
Merit a much higher penalty because the
same offender committed similar offenses
um in in other states so I think um so I
think even if we could do it I don't
think it would be a good idea to try to
prevent the federal judges from
exercising their discretion so all right
uh representative Perez on the other
hand it could make
judges
rethink or go along with what a
prosecutor may have it could be either
change the prosecutor or change the
judge I think more and more people are
not given or are pressured into not
exercising the right of a trial and I
find that very sad right other com
representative
Stapleton yeah I I think this case
getting too far into the weeds which we
shouldn't really be doing but I got a
question is there does a person have a
right of appeal on the
sentencing it well it I mean in in state
in the in the state court
practice
um the
the the general answer to that is no
because it is agreed upon in other words
if the
the there's a big difference between I
think this may be part of there's a big
between state and federal in state
practice a plea
bargain means that the parties have
agreed to the plea
bargain and the
judge H if if the judge either accepts
The Plea or rejects it but what the
judge can't do is accept the plea and
then impose a harsher sentence with one
caveat there is what is called in the
system a cap plea which means that for
example the the parties can
agree that the that the um that the
maximum that the judge can can impose
for example if he accepts this plea is
let's say 10 years in prison but the
defendant reserves his right to argue
for Less um but the defendant knows that
he is exposed
to the the a maximum of 10 years even
though the statute might say the maximum
of 15 years the parties have agreed uh
to the cap and and if the judge wants to
accept that plea he is bound by that
agreement in the federal system it is
considerably different um the the judge
with some exceptions but generally the
judge whether there's a plea or not
retains the right to impose the sentence
that within the limits of the law that
the judge feels is appropriate so there
there's more of a risk in the federal
system than there is in the in the state
system and I I don't know that any of
the details of this person's agreement
but I think you know that may well
explain what what happened in his case I
don't know but that so that case was a
federal it was a federal case yes it was
a federal case Okay representative tur
yeah just one quick comment I I I don't
feel that this legislation should go
forward but uh I did sort of want to and
I think maybe in a couple of comments
around the table it did feel like at at
its core the question of whether or not
huge differential um potential sentences
between standard sentencing versus what
a plea can go down to does have the
potential to to at some level thwart
people's you know ability to to to seek
you know a trial so yeah no I I I I mean
I do age I agree at some point I think
that's probably that that probably is
true and I think you know
most hopefully most judges would take
that you know they might in other words
I think it probably there is an
Institutional interest
in resolving cases that make it
appropriate I think for the system to
offer a reward to somebody who is
willing to accept responsibility and
avoid a trial and all that but there I
agree that there is a limit to that it
can't you know it it it shouldn't
be like you know a Hu just a huge Hammer
um and and sometimes I think it probably
is uh particularly in the federal system
but anyway um all right are we ready uh
for the motion is itl on 1497 are we
ready for a vote all right I ask the
clerk to call the role please vas
chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep Khan yes rep
Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep gon yes
clerk votes yes rep Perez
no rep
Smith rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo yes
re Kenny yes rep
Sebert yes rep Divine yes rep lonza yes
rep Manos yes rep Tura yes rep Ming
yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes 19
to1
um uh consent uh any any objection to
going on consent representative for all
right consent and um I
will write the
report uh okay moving right along all
right moving along um
1602 um I'm going to w recognize
representative Alexander um thank you Mr
chair I'll move HB 1602 to interm study
and uh is there a second I would second
it all right representative Manos uh
seconds um representative Alexander you
wish to speak to your motion yeah I I
think still this being my bill I think
there's a lot of Merit to this bill I
think that um when when speaking about
housing issues it's important to make
sure state agencies understand that
housing
is per the citizens of New Hampshire one
of the biggest problems facing our state
and I'd like to see um this become a
true interm study where the members of
this committee that would like to join
me and look into how state agencies are
dealing with permits related to housing
in particular um in other rulings they
would join me in a nice summer recess um
into this committee room and we can look
into that I spoke with Dees and they
indicated there's a lot of things that
they're doing on the rues side to
expedite some of these um permits um you
know they think there's a simple rule
change they can make to move not just
the workforce housing um permits to the
top of the pile which is already allowed
under RSA but all housing permits to the
top of the pile because I believe
strongly if we are increasing the supply
of housing it doesn't matter what the
housing is if we get it built it'll help
lower the price for everybody so I hope
that you'll um at least support me and
you don't have to be a part of this but
um at least allow me the opportunity to
study this more thank you any other uh
comments I I I think what you propos
makes perfect sense so are we ready for
a vote on the motion is interim
study Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Anders yes rep con yes
re Stapleton yes rep trip yes re gson
yes cler votes yes rep perz yes rep
Smith rep Horgan yes rep dorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes re Sebert yeah rep Divine yes
rep lonza yes rep Manos yes rep CH yes
rep Ming yes chairman Lynn yes motion
passes 20 all right uh
consent anyone
okay go on consent all right
um turning to uh House Bill 1614 uh the
chair recognizes representative Manos
for a motion thank you Mr chair um I
have an amendment that um I would like
um
represent could I just ask are you
passing it out just for discussion or I
I was under the impression there was
going to be an i an interim study mode
yes I am g i i but I wanted to have to
have have the amendment and see the
amendment but yes I am going to move
interim study this is a bill which um
and with the amendment which allows in
um Dees cases uh once it has gone
through um a hearing with the you may
remember there are four special councils
in Dees that hear appeals and then after
that the only appeal would be to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court and the gist of
this amendment is that it would
allow um a complainant
to the situation that arises is the um
is the science is overcoming is
developing faster than the um than the
Appellate process and so in order to be
able to open up the acceptance of new
evidence um this amendment allows the
complaintant to file a complaint with
the Superior
Court however um in thinking about the
bill further and in talking with other
people it became clear that this um
applies across the board to any number
of administrative agencies and so the
question becomes whether this should be
broader than just Dees and why have we
singled out Dees in particular and so
I'm moving inm study so that we can look
at the broader issues and can consider
whether um we should be looking at other
um the broader
totality um and so that's why I'm moving
in term study all right is there a
second on the motion for study seconded
by representative Alexander um
representative Alexander did you want to
speak at so you know what I I I think
I'm completely in support of the interim
study the only thing that I would ask um
the people that are going to be involved
in the interim study on both of these uh
1602 and this and and if you want me to
I'm happy to you know spend at least
devote at least some of my summer to
working on this not not the majority but
some um the only thing I'd ask you to uh
think about is to be sure
that the the idea of move of of
streamlining the process I think is
particularly important for the reasons
that Al just uh representative Alexander
mentioned
um I think you need to be careful though
that in doing that you don't create like
another level of I mean for example this
this amendment that you just discussed
representative Manos it might be it
might be good but it does create another
another level of review which might mean
that things get slowed down so just
something to think about as you're as
you're doing it but the motion is um uh
interim study uh anybody have anything
further they want to say on that all
right then I'd ask the clerk to call the
RO
please Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep con
yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep
gon yes clerk attab votes yes rep Perez
yes rep Smith yes rep orgon yes rep
dorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep Sebert
yeah rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep
Manos yes rep T yes rep Ming yes
chairman Lynn yes motion passes 2 all
right consent consent all
right I think we did I think we did uh
pretty sure we did yes we did we did all
right and um representative Manos can I
ask you to prepare the report thank you
all right next we're on to uh 1640
relative to qualified immunity standards
the chair recognized representative
Alexander for a motion thank you Mr
chair I move this in expedient to
legislate is there a
Perez all right uh representative
Alexandri would you like to speak to
your motion yes yes briefly um this is
one of these bills that um has come up I
believe six out of the six years I've
been on this committee um we've we
looked at similar legislation last year
as well I think there's things that this
bill similar to the last year still do
not solve language wise um first of all
um this would create a cause of action
through a violation of um the con State
of New Hampshire Constitution or Federal
Constitution um there's there's really
no standard on negligence so if any
employee violates a right um whether
they did it intentionally or not the
state is held liable this is going to
open up the flood gates to lawsuits to
municipalities um additionally I asked
the question during the public hearing
about um the new Constitutional
Amendment regarding right to privacy
that's now a constitutional amendment
per the voters in the 2018 election so I
I asked if 91a would follow under that
um you know and the attorney said yes I
I have a real problem over um I
understand 91a should not be violated
but this would open up um a ton of
lawsuits on if a if a town intentionally
or unintentionally violated 91a um this
would open up this lawsuit so um there's
already Immunity on the books for when
an individual uh acts in a wanting or
Reckless way um and that's clearly
defined in in case law so um for that
reason I think that we should continue
the tradition of um trusting that most
employees um most government officials
act in a um decent and um positive way
and we should trust that we continue to
do that while also holding the ones that
do not accountable and making sure we're
training all of our employees correctly
so that's it any other anyone else wish
to be heard on uh House Bill
1640 all right and are we ready for vote
the motion is
itl vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes re con yes
re steton yes re trip yes re gon yes
clerk have votes yes rep
Perez rep Smith rep Horgan yes rep D
Lorenzo yes RB Kenny yes RB
Sebert yes rep Divine yes rep lonza yes
rep Manos yes rep CH yes rep Ming yes
chairman Lynn yes motion passes 20 to0
all right
consent and representative Alexander uh
can I ask you to write the report yes
thank
you all right um next I want to turn to
1664 um and
um I think everyone should
have
received
um uh
a proposed amendment drafted by
representative h i told representative H
when he informed me that he was going to
be submitting an amendment that I would
present the amendment to the committee
to see if anybody on the committee
wanted to move the amendment but that I
was not willing to move the amendment
because I don't favor the bill and the
amendment doesn't doesn't change my view
on the bill but if anybody if anybody
you know the amendment is here and if
anybody it's Amendment
0972 if somebody wants to move the
amendment we can and it's seconded we
can uh yes representative Perez I'd like
to move uh to pass with amendment of
972h all right is there a
second second by representative gon all
second all right uh representative Perez
would you wish to would you wish to
speak to your amend uh to the amendment
no but I have asked um representative
hul to be here to speak to it for me am
I allowed to do that that where we had
somebody else be able to do
that sure I yes representative h i I
don't want to have a long discussion but
sure you you may speak to
it thank you Mr chair members of
Judiciary during the public testimony on
this bill there was lots of questions
regarding when does Discovery start what
triggers Discovery in a medical
malpractice suit there was also
questions relative to the length of time
that a person undergoing a d transition
treatment could have access to medical
malpractice liability standards those
causes of action are already in statute
today there's a three-year time limit
there's a beginning of the discovery
window when the when the patient
realizes harm was done that's when the
clock starts ticking this amendment
adopts the language that is in the
Senate version Senate Bill
304 that is the beginning of that
Discovery window happens when the person
begins a d transition that would be like
some action whether they saw another
doctor and and did something different
whether they discontinued taking certain
medications or whether they
um um started taking in the case of
taking hormones they went from taking
estrogen back to testosterone or vice
versa so at that point there's a
positive action on the part of the of
the patient and that makes an easy time
zero so this just clarifies where in the
law um a transition a d transition would
have access to any medical malpractice
all right thank you um all right uh any
anyone else wish to uh be heard on this
uh yes representative
Perez so I have a acquaintance who has a
child that is
detransitioning and I think we have
worked very hard to make
um to attempt to and to make some um
laws for people transitioning and I real
feel very strongly that we have really
no guide guidance or
no support or anything for those that
are
detransitioning and there are thousands
and thousands and thousands of uh
individuals that are attempting to undo
what they feel they did wrong to
themselves and or was done wrong to them
and I think we need a way to allow them
to have a back end to fight um for what
was done to them so I feel very strongly
that this by the amendment I didn't like
the age 18 20 years and all this stuff
but I think this
amendment does support support
detransitioning individuals who also
have a
right all right other anyone else wish
to be heard on this yes representative
kab thank you Mr
chairman I guess it it still troubles me
in this amendment that somebody a
50-year-old who chooses to take
medication to transition could then go
and a doctor because they changed their
mind about it and I just
if an adult makes a decision of their
own free will why aren't they liable for
it why is the doctor doctor liable for
it I just don't even this concept
doesn't make any sense to me so for that
reason I'll be voting against it thank
you anyone else wish to be heard chair
yes representative D Lorenzo um yes I'd
like to respond to representative
Perez's um statement that thousands and
thousands of children have are going
through this um do representative press
do you mean in New Hampshire or
throughout the
country I mean throughout the country
but there are many here too if you um go
on to if you are allowed to go on to
some of the detransitioning which I had
authorization by an individual
detransitioning to go they have a
support group and there are a lot of
young individuals from New Hampshire
that are attempting to d d transition go
follow up please of course yeah just so
that I can get an idea of the scope of
the number in New Hampshire what do you
have um for a number in New Hampshire or
people detransitioning thank you I don't
have number but I think we need to
protect people even if it's one just
like we need to protect children even if
it's
one other
comments um all right so I guess what I
the only the only thing that I would say
about this is I told this to
representative who is
um I voted in favor and I know many
people on this committee did not but I
voted in favor and I think a number of
people on the committee also voted in
favor of the bill we recently passed uh
to prohibit uh trans just
transitioning surgery for miners um
personally I would if I would be be
amenable I I guess I want to see exactly
what was proposed but I would be
amenable to Banning for miners um even
non-surgical
transitioning
um but this the problem I have with this
bill is it that it would basically say
even though
that may even though nonsurgical or or
at least right now even surgical
transitioning of minors is legal we're
somehow going to be able to go after the
doctors um so or somebody's going to be
able to go after the doctors way later
on the analogy I drew to representative
Hol and I think it applies is that's
like saying you know the we're going to
go after the Firearms manufacturers
because somebody shot somebody with a
gun um that it's that that it's not the
person that that made the decision to do
that it's GNA it's the it's the big bad
Firearms manufacturers I don't support
that and I can't support this um so
anyway other
comments all right um I guess then we're
ready for a vote the the vote is on the
amendment uh by representative Perez
moved by representative Perez seconded
by representative gon it's Doc it's
number
72h Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep con
yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep
gon yes CL kab votes no rep
Perez clarification we're voting on on
rep
Smith rep Horgan no rep De Lorenzo no
rep Kenny no rep
Sebert no rep Divine no rep lonza no rep
Manos no repur no rep Ming no chairman
Lynn
no motion fails 8
to2
all right um now we're back to the uh
main bill um representative Alexander do
you have a motion on the no I don't you
don't not okay all right um is there any
other
motion I to pass all right uh motion is
ought to pass is there a
second right second by representative uh
gon
um and representative Perez you wish to
speak to your uh
motion we need to start something to
help those
who feel that
they
were made decisions were forc or pushed
or coerced into making that seems to be
a big word right now coerced into making
decisions that they later regretted and
I think we need to start helping them
and again as is said so many times today
if the bill is imperfect we can ask the
legislators to change it later all right
any other anyone else representative
gon I wonder why we sneer at the idea
that somebody would change their
mind we we think going from male to
female or female to to male you're born
biologically male and you be want to
transition to
female but somehow or another it's
different than if you wanted to go back
to being male from being female that
somehow or another that's not possible
or that's ridiculous nobody wants to do
that or there should not be any
protections similar to going from one to
the other you're not allowed to change
your mind is what it sounds like to
me and I do believe that a lot of people
are caught up in a world of confusion
and there's pressure to conform to
things that maybe they don't really want
to conform to but they're not sure what
they want to do and so they're making
decisions that have long lasting effects
they're
irreversible severe consequences to it
and there just needs to be a measure
involved to try to protect those people
who said wow I think I've gone too far
in this I got to try to go back to some
semblance of sanity
other comments representative
kutab so I would absolutely agree if
somebody transitioned and they want to
go back they should absolutely be able
to do so I just I don't feel that if you
used inform consent to consent to taking
medications and chose to take the
medications that the doctor should be
liable that you changed your mind I
guess that's the part that I'm kind of
hung up on and again like this bill
doesn't just apply to to miners either
it applies to a yearold chooses to take
the medication when they're 50 and then
they change their mind when they're 60 I
just I'm not sure why a doctor should be
liable
for a patient changing their mind after
they've given informed consent that's
that to me that's would be a similar
concept to if a man chose to have a
vasectomy or a woman chose to have her
tubes tied and then they changed their
mind we're going to now say that the
doctor civil liable
that the patient changed their mind I
just I guess that's a part that I don't
doesn't make sense to me thank you
representative
Stapleton yeah thank you Mr chair
um cultural pressure peer
pressure um just the ongoing way our
society has
transitioned um is almost
uh a difficult Force for young people to
resist um did we have any test testimony
that this kind of bill passed in
Virginia and had a great chilling effect
upon transitional surgeries and or am I
thinking of another I think I think I
think it was Missouri not Virginia if I
recall correctly I think that I thought
that's what representative po had told
me that was Missouri that passed it
okay no it's all right I don't think it
makes much I I was wondering if this
bill was based on that Virginia Missouri
or what whatever that's yeah I think it
was I think it was based on some
other no no I just I mean it was some
other I think it was some other state as
I
understand so Tim oh yes representative
Oregon yes I'm trying to wrap my head
around the idea that large numbers of
people are being coerced to go into a
gender transition which in spite of what
some people believe is really one of the
most difficult things a person can do
and is something that
um I just and also I just don't
understand why how you could C someone
into doing something that difficult
unless the person who was doing the
transitioning was pretty highly
motivated to to do it especially given
that um just about everything in our
society most other societ is very
divided into male and females so I think
if somebody's Crossing that line and
then would always sort of be at
least I'm not sure why somebody would
cross that line unless they really
really deeply felt that they they wanted
they wanted to so I just don't exactly
know what these people are supposed toly
coursing young people into changing
their gender what they're gaining from
it so it seems me the social pressure is
all the other way to stay in the same uh
gender to which you were assigned at at
at Birth and um I might also start a
question the idea of biological sex is
more Central than your gender identity
unless I think like what what you
believe yourself to be is more important
than what you present as and way you
present on is obviously much more
important than like so-called biological
things you like you especially you know
the X and Y chromosomes which we can't
even see and we and which were only
discovered in the last century or so
long before people had the concept of
male and female which they voice that so
I just don't quite
understand how you can successfully
course someone into changing their
changing their their gender unless they
unless the person who is doing the
changing really strongly felt that they
wanted to do it so all right other
representative D Lorenzo thank you Mr
chair not withstanding this
bill people who are medically injured
have a right
um to damages recover damages um on
account of medical injury uh and that's
based in talk to IT contract law or
otherwise so if we take out the um
transitional aspect of this bill it's
still on its face if a person is injured
medically injured they um are entitled
to damages period no matter what the um
procedure is thank you right other
representative fore first of all
children do not have a right an ability
Maybe to give informed consent so it is
not them that are giving the informed
consent
secondly I know you're not going to like
this but we just passed to go to the
house a bill that everybody has said
it's only going to be a few people very
rare very rare that are going to want to
have medical assisted termination of
life but yet we are talking about people
who need to
protected mostly people who had this
done as children as un
non-adults from being offered some
protection to write a wrong that they
feel was done to them I I it's
mindboggling to me that we can sit here
on one hand and say one thing and sit
here on another hand and say another
thing it's like this is real and I'll do
respect representative Horgan this is
happening every single day planned
parenthood is giving out the drugs here
in New Hampshire every single day and
the surgery is being done every single
day and in Massachusetts you're paying
for the surgery so I mean it is going on
these people need to be protected
too representative de I'd like to follow
up on us representative PR's statements
first of all um the surgery is not just
for children it's for adults and
children all generations secondly um do
you have any statistics to back up your
um inferences about the volume of
surgeries that are going on you said in
New Hampshire and Massachusetts do you
have any back up on
that thank
you thank
you all right representative
Smith uh thank you I'm I'm I'm following
up on representative D Lorenzo's Point
could you give me the documentation of
par Call
Dairy go on theirs and they will say
that they offer hormone
and transition really yes really or call
them thank
you right any other comments any other
there right all right um any other
comments so I guess I I I I know I'm
repeating myself and I apologize but
the the problem I have is this as I
think representative kab pointed out it
this we're saying this is this this is
just like the the there was a recent New
Hampshire Supreme Court case that you
probably all very very recent dealing
with the immunity statute for firearms
dealers and under the law the Firearms
dealer legally sold the handgun to the I
think it was a handgun or whatever it
was uh to the person who shot the police
officers but the police and that and it
was
legal the police the police officers
decided to bring a suit against the
dealer the theory being that well it
might have been legal but you really
shouldn't have sold the gun that's the
that was the theory that to me was was a
crazy area and the New Hampshire Supreme
Court made the right decision we would
be doing sort of the same thing here
it's all right to to perform these
surgeries it's legal which maybe it
should be may I I would tend to say it
shouldn't be but it is it's legal and
what we're going to do is go after the
doctor for doing something that was
legal um I don't see how that makes any
sense and as representative D Lorenzo
pointed out if there has really been
some malpractice
um the the minor has a claim for for
that kind of malpractice just like they
would have for any other malpractice so
I I don't see any reason for this sort
of special
bill um other other uh representative
Stapleton boy it's really hair splitting
um with good points on both sides of
this I just
wonder
um
lost
it
um Physicians are they not held to a
higher standard and that's the last
resort for reasonable
decision parents come to the physician
for Trans treatment with the
child and
um the the physician has to make an
evaluation not only just write the order
and say yes but investigate a little bit
and query a little bit to see if uh
there's something wrong here or they
should step back from it sure I think I
think so there's held to the standard of
care of a reasonable physician in those
circumstan I would think that that
absolutely would impose upon the phys
that's what this bill does it it puts
the onus on the position to be the last
bull workk but that I mean that that
onus already exists under existing law
if the if the physician has hasn't done
that they're liable under existing law
yeah it may be redundant but but it's an
Awakening all right other yes
representative
Perez I have a problem with the fact
that we can't call
made committing suicide but we can
compare a a person's human body to a
gun I have a problem with that I just
need to make that known I have I do not
see a comparison with a
gun and a human body
so right other
comments all right I guess we're ready
the motion before us is
OTP um and I asked the clerk to call the
role Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander rep Andrews yes rep con yes
rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes yes rep
gon yes clerk kab votes no rep Perez yes
rep Smith no rep orgon no rep D Lorenzo
no rep Kenny no rep
cybert no rep Divine no rep lonza
no rep Manos no rep tur no rep Ming no
12 is there a motion is there another
motion representative
Smith representative CH will oh I'm
sorry representative CH yeah can I make
second all right U anything further you
wish to say all right so I think we're
itl Vice chairman Wallace No rep
Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
sorry thank you rep con rep Stapleton no
no rep trip no rep
gon clerk kab votes yes rep
Perez rep
Smith rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo yes
rep Kenny yes rep
paage I'm
yes um rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep
Manos yes rep tur yes rep Ming
yes motion passes 12
to8 um all right representative tur I
think you're up for the writing the
report will there be a Minority Report
and if so who will
minority
um all right we're down one more to go
folks all right um the clerk a minute to
catch up with the subs yeah yeah no take
your time I can relate all right so last
one is uh house bill um
1684 uh relative to uh loss of
Consortium um and
uh hang on one
second do I have uh a motion with regard
to
that um can I may I of course so I want
just I wanted to bring forward um rep
Reed did put together um amendment
number 2024
d932
which had addressed some of the concerns
and I didn't know if the committee cared
voting Mr chair has anyone introduced
that I don't believe any I don't believe
anyone has some if someone wants to move
it that's uh that's fine I'm I'm not
inclined to do so but if somebody wants
to all right seeing none
all right representative D Lorenzo moves
it is there a second I'll second it
right seconded by representative Kenny
all right um what's the amendment number
again then 932 H
heno
okay all right representative D Lorenzo
do you wish to speak to your
motion
um I'm speaking on the amendment and I
would like to vote o to pass on the
amendment all right all right anyone
else wish to uh speak to the um
Amendment it's seeing none I guess the
only thing I I I do wish speaker and I
basically would say I
the um I don't see any oh you don't have
everybody oh here yeah do I have yeah no
I do have it I do have it yeah yes thank
you
two yeah add
right yeah I oh um Mr chair yes I need
to resend that Mo motion I was just
informed that the motion was all to pass
and
I don't want to do that oh trying to do
a courtesy to my member from my district
oh okay all right all right so uh repres
representative D Lorenzo uh withdraws
her motion and represent can you
withdraw your second I take it all right
so um do we have a uh we're now back to
the main bill is there a motion of
ITA somebody want to move all right
representative Perez moves
itl um is there a second second by
representative
Stapleton all right um representative
Perez do you wish to speak to your
motion no all
right that's fine sorry representative
Stapleton anything you wants to say yeah
I give it a few words um I didn't see
any value or much of a value in the
amendment and I don't see any value in
the underlying Bill uh I think it goes
over the fence relative to the
traditional
lawful um definition of Consortium and
expands it what else is next beyond that
uh I I just think it's not a good way to
go so I'm opposed to I'm I'm for the itl
all right any other representative Kenny
uh thank you Mr chairman so I fully
understand the slipy slope argument and
I fully understand why people are
supporting itl um some of you may know
may not know I used to be chair of the
animal protection caucus with Kathy
Rogers um so although I don't think this
bill is necessarily ready for prime time
and I don't and I know the amendment
didn't have enough support um I am going
to vote against itl but I fully
understand why everyone is um voting the
way they are thank you all right any
other comment representative Smith um
thank you I'm not sure that
representative Kenny um was over covid
when we had the hearing when
representatives of the American Kennel
Club and a number of other um
very well respected uh entities
interested in Animal Welfare all
bill representative Kenny other than the
AKC do you know the other
remember that's I'm that's I'm wondering
where they fell on it
right I I guess I'm wondering whether
the Humane Society fell on it or if they
position
right they weren't here any any other
comments on uh on
1684 all right the motion is itl um uh
by representative Perez seconded by
representative Stapleton I ask the clerk
to call the role please Vice chairman
Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews
yes rep con yes rep Stapleton yes rep
trip yes rep gon yes clerk kab votes yes
rep
Perez I'm sorry yes rep
Smith rep Horgan yes rep De Lorenzo yes
rep
Kenny
sorry rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep
Manos yes repur yes thank you rep Ming
yes chairman Lynn
yes 19 to one can that go on consent yes
no objection all right consent and uh
representative Perez I think you're up
for the
it all
right all right so
um I'm I'm I think we're done and I'm
actually I'm
uh I'm pleasantly surprised I thought it
was going to take longer than it longer
than longer than it did um so for those
for those who are writing reports please
have them have it to me by the end of
the day on Friday if you would please um
and um for representative uh Manos and
gon and uh well cor Mr Corman is gone
representative Corman is gone but I will
be in touch uh probably on Friday by
trying to set something up as quickly uh
as possible on our subcommittee um
pardon and yes so and thank you to thank
you to both of our substitutes for your
participation today and they uh it's
been very helpful and we appreciate it
all right
um all right uh any anything further we
need to talk
adjourned